The joe rogan experience
while I'm on.
Pretty easy.
Huh?
How do I know for sure?
Exactly.
That's the key.
I think that's eventually going to be the whole world.
You were just going to be online.
I wouldn't doubt it.
I mean it looked the size of these cameras.
I'm shocked.
I was expecting to see this big studio with like do to do this is Hollywood.
Yeah.
This is tiny little cameras.
A normal consumer grade,
you know,
and that's basically what it is.
I mean we have a new ones that are high definition ones that we haven't worked
the kinks out yet.
That'll be up shortly.
But uh,
other than that,
just regular cameras.
And this is actually like,
just like this,
the background,
everything's on.
This is online like right now.
Yeah.
We can show it to you if you want.
You see it?
Show it to you.
I'm one of the screens.
Yeah,
that's,
that's really cool.
I spend a little bit of time out in the mountain so I don't get the little bit a
little bit.
You live online right now.
We'll wait.
Cool.
So,
uh,
I saw your show,
the new show and the old show.
I've seen them online,
um,
from,
I guess the last couple of years.
And for folks who don't know,
Jim Shockey,
you're famous,
a hunter,
a famous,
uh,
outdoorsman,
conservationist,
all the above.
But you're,
uh,
your new show is what really drew me in when I really started tweeting about it.
The show uncharted,
where,
I mean there's shows that transcend the genre that they're in.
You know,
there's shows that like,
they might,
it might be a comedy show,
but there's more to it.
It might be a drama,
but it's,
this show is very difficult to define this uncharted show cause it's almost like
a documentary on these strange cultures that you're visiting.
Yeah.
With hunting as,
as the,
as the underlying reason we're there.
Um,
and the theme when we're in those places,
you know,
what,
what's going on with the hunting in those crazy wild lands.
Um,
then I,
you know,
just for,
I mean,
before we even go one step further,
I've got to say,
I like to take full credit for it,
but it's,
uh,
it's our son Brandon,
you know,
this is his brainchild.
He,
he actually,
you know,
I've done television hunting shows and you've seen the hunting shows.
I mean,
they started my original ones a zillion years ago.
Now we're pretty bad.
Like,
hi,
I'm Jim Shockey.
This is my big buck,
you know.
But,
uh,
you know,
Brandon wanted to do something that would change television.
Like literally that,
that was,
that was his goal was to change television the way you watch television.
And,
and uh,
you know,
I said,
absolutely.
If it's,
if it's art,
which I think,
you know,
we don't get enough credit in as hunters.
They,
people think,
oh,
we're just louts,
you know,
swilling beer,
shooting out the window of the truck and,
and,
and causing havoc.
Well,
that's,
that's not what hunters are,
you know,
hunters have some of the highest sensibilities you can possibly have there.
They're tuned into nature like nobody else.
Maybe mountaineers.
I mean,
you read mountaineering books,
those guys,
they're also switched on for that.
But,
uh,
your brand wanted to try and capture that and,
and the cultures are on the road.
I,
that's,
that's uncharted.
Yeah.
I think it's a very unfortunate aspect of our culture that we live in this weird
insulated world where people are so detached from the meat they eat and where it
comes from,
that they view the people who go out and get it themselves.
And the most difficult circumstances,
they've used those people to be less intelligent,
have a low moral standards.
They view them to be drunks.
And I don't know how it happened that hunter's got lumped into this strange
group,
but I was having a conversation with a friend of mine online the other day and
he was having these,
he was making these accusations about hunters and I was like,
do you actually even know any hunters?
Like,
are you just like basing this on like an episode of bugs bunny that's like,
what is this is,
you know what it is?
It's a,
I mean,
I'm old enough to remember Walt Disney when he did Bambi,
that son of a gun,
I'm telling you,
that was the day that was the day that,
that the pendulum starts swinging in the other direction.
And we,
in the popular press became that guy that killed Bambi,
his mother.
I mean,
oh God.
You know,
Walt,
while I'm down here,
I'm actually going to see if I can have a visit with them and go piss on his
grave.
Well,
yeah.
Oh,
I know.
Because he also,
he also did Pollyanna and some great movies,
but uh,
but,
uh,
you know,
he,
that's where it started.
And,
and to be fair,
to be fair,
you know,
go back 19,
say 50s,
you know,
you've got Howard Roark and Hemingway foot on top,
other lion,
you know,
with their gun up.
And these guys,
you know,
there's no wonder there was a backlash,
especially by females.
I mean [inaudible] what did he brag about?
And I apologize if I get the numbers wrong,
but how many women he slept with in his life?
I mean,
and that's fine.
That's fine.
But it went against everything that was family and,
and what this country and Canada was built on,
you know,
the foundation.
So these,
these guys were,
they were showing us,
you know,
bores and no offense on,
and I,
and I Apologize Hemingway if you're listening or Rourke,
but they did us no service.
So when,
when Disney came in and did Bambi,
that was it,
you know,
and then,
and that was the same time,
roughly approximately one a Kennedy was shot.
So now you had this whole gun thing and you know,
the hippie movement and Wham were,
we're,
we are,
I guess,
a alienated or certainly marginalized,
uh,
as,
as human beings.
And,
and since 1960,
you know,
so this,
this is what we've been fighting.
And now finally,
you know,
we,
we did not have access to any press.
We had no way to tell our message where we,
you know,
we had American sportsman with curt Gowdy.
That was up until 1962,
she'll cancel,
gone goodbye.
Or whenever it was canceled.
Uh,
we had no way,
no way to access,
uh,
the,
the airwaves,
you know,
the,
the three major networks,
they want to know part of hunters,
they would,
you know,
they wanted to show Bambi or,
or,
you know,
anything else that was similar and they,
we had no way to talk.
We had no way to tell people our story other than magazines,
which of course television superseded that very quickly.
So it's only been in the last,
you know,
10 really 10 years that we've started to reach into the households,
with,
with outdoor channels,
like the outdoor channel,
literally.
And that's,
even though that's sort almost preaching to the choir a bit.
Yeah.
Unfortunately the,
and that there's,
there's economics,
right?
Who's,
who buys that network?
Well,
it's,
it's a case of you have to buy the households
before you're going to get distribution into those households.
So your cost money,
I mean,
I don't know what the numbers are,
say $4 a household and ends up being,
it's
pensive.
I feel like there's a swing in the other direction now in a pretty big way.
And I think one of the reasons why is these,
um,
these shows like life below zero and these Alaska mountain men shows where
they're showing people living off the land and it,
it paints this attractive view of living this sustenance lifestyle.
Yeah.
So simpler,
simpler lifestyle.
I mean,
I,
I still have issues with how they portray the characters.
I mean,
they still want that,
you know,
they don't want to see somebody who's articulate can form a whole sense.
Not,
not saying those guys can't,
but you know,
they still want know to build a justify watching it.
They want to see them being a little bit different.
You know what I mean?
Look at,
uh,
look at Phil and William.
The guys on Duck Dynasty,
they,
you know,
they're allowed because they've got the big beards and their talk funny.
So,
okay,
well we can let them hunt,
you know,
but they don't want to see somebody that is,
looks like them hunting.
It doesn't compute inside their brains because that's not what hunters are.
Why don't think it's necessarily that they don't want to see it.
It's just that they're trying to sell.
They're trying to sell television,
the way to sell television to show freaks,
to show honey booboo and show Weirdos and these duck guys live in the swamps
with these crazy beards.
You know,
that's what people will tune into a will or he didn't mean that about being
freaks.
I did.
I just tried to stick up for William.
He needs to stick up for himself.
You know,
Willie's been telling people to watch the new Nicholas cage movie to prepare for
the a apocalypse.
I haven't heard that.
I'll play it for I feel like is the reckoning or what have you.
Yeah,
I mean but yeah,
that's,
that's what people want to see.
They want to see different,
want to see a free cause they don't want to say normal.
They want to see the Kardashians.
Dysfunctional family.
You know what that has to change.
That has to change because we can't keep feeding people that swill and expected,
you know,
what,
what's going to happen with the country and uh,
10 years of that.
Have you been so dumbed down you won't even be able to remember how to breathe.
I think it is changing.
I
think what we're dealing with is like the last throes,
like the last dying twitches of our culture.
Making this weird shift into the age of information and along the way you're
just going to give people is anything to keep them occupied and people,
they don't have communication with their neighbors,
they don't.
The the gossip that they get is like gossip at work.
I come in and work,
this motherfucker always wants to talk to me about Kanye West is getting
divorced and this guy's in trouble and Jay z got an argument with his girlfriend
and like the these people that live in this culture today.
A lot of it,
and I'm not Jamie,
a very intelligent guy,
but he loves pop culture.
We are,
we're constantly inundated with stuff that's,
that's flashy and distracting and nonsensical things that don't mean anything.
And I think a lot of it is just because of the way human beings live.
I think a lot of it is the way people live in these neighborhoods where they
don't know anybody and we have a desire for gossip.
We have a desire to,
to talk shit about people and to,
to like hear what the secrets are and what the dirt is.
And I think these shows feed that they feed into that they give you this world
that you can pay attention to,
that's way more screwed up than your world is.
And it's right in front of your face and you can tune in every night and you get
engrossed and caught up in his character.
One guy owns a pawn shop and his dad's always sleeping and you know,
and you watch this dumb show and you wasted a half an hour of your time.
And because of clever editing and because they put these Weirdos in front of you
and just interesting enough to keep you paying attention before you know,
what your hours gone.
Like,
what happened?
What did you just stole something from my life.
He did a dance for me.
And yeah,
he would wave the clock in front of my face,
you know,
Tick Tock and you hypnotize me,
you know?
Uh,
speaking of that,
actually,
uh,
I've been caught on that because it's true when you're,
oh,
you're saying it that way.
I mean,
I was caught up in the Arctic here this year.
We were watching a,
I couldn't get out on the land for a hunt,
so we were trapped in a little tiny hotel room,
which will hotel,
there was like a trailer divided up into compartments and on television was
reruns of storage wars and they,
the one storage,
the guy had bought a vault.
It was just a safe,
and I watched the whole darn show and rental rental attest to this event is
listening.
Another way,
you can't do it on line,
but uh,
you know,
there is nothing more important.
I watched every commercial so I wouldn't miss the opening of that stupid safe
and it,
and they open it up and there's nothing in it.
It's like,
oh my goodness.
Gotcha.
Oh,
of course they did.
And that you said it.
I mean,
they,
they dumb us down.
They don't want us,
they,
they like,
they hook us on sugar and there's at the end of it,
you're still hungry but you don't feel sated yet.
You're,
you know,
you're,
you're 20 pounds heavier than you were when you started the show.
So it's a or 20 Iq points lighter,
less.
Uh,
and I,
I ma,
I just,
I just have hope.
I mean,
I,
I don't always,
there's times when I,
when I despair,
you know,
when,
uh,
when I look at this big picture,
cause I,
you know,
I look at it from an outside objective view.
You talked about Jay Z and,
and,
and k west or something like that.
I have no idea who those guys are.
And they are assuming their guys.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I spent a lot of time on a mountain top looking at the world and,
and you know,
there's times I just despair and,
and,
and then,
then I'll tell you honestly,
and they said,
this is a compliment to you.
You know,
I get a tweet like that where you,
you saw what we're producing and someone in this place,
and this isn't,
you know,
no offense,
but you're not far from Hollywood,
which got to be around here somewhere.
I had to have driven to,
it is $100 for the cab ride from the airport to here.
So I must've come unless they got it
took me on a tour.
I have no idea.
It's probably just the traffic.
Yeah,
it was.
I mean,
you're close to that.
But again,
back to the compliment,
you know,
I'm here for one reason because you're standing up for good things.
Things that are important.
And you know,
in my world that's the hunting and to,
to bring it to the forefront and you'll take the heat.
You know,
I,
I saw some of the comments about you and whatnot with your hunting and how
you've had to define what you're doing is hunting,
eating the meat.
And I respect that you are standing up the,
and that's hence the reason there's,
you know,
a zillion people watch your podcasts and listen to what you say.
I mean,
we were listening to it in,
uh,
Tanzania this last month.
Wow.
One of my cameraman is a huge fan.
He's probably listening right now.
Hey John,
what's up John?
He,
he's,
he's probably,
they say,
listen right now he had your,
your podcast with Steve Rinella.
So,
and it was fascinating.
I mean,
you're reaching out and educating people about what hunting is about and you
know,
from the meat side and,
and that perspective and it's fantastic.
All support that any day and that,
that gives me hope.
So when I stand up there and,
and look at this picture of this world,
it was just like you say,
it's been honey booboo wise,
do you,
you,
you know,
there,
there's really,
it's just despair.
I just see the big mass of despair until these tiny little voice has come up,
you know,
and,
and you're making an attempt and you're reaching people and you're fighting and
that,
you know,
that's why I'm here.
That's,
that's hope.
There is hope that
people are just not that stupid.
No,
they're not.
They're not that stupid.
They're not in just like you,
you got roped into watching this stupid store to storage wars show.
Excuse me.
That was a safe thing.
That was,
that was different.
That was different.
There is a safe and they see the had to be something in that.
You remember Al Capone's vault?
I do with her other.
There was like a special live episode.
Like what kind of a fool like opens up this stupid vault live hoping it's
something you name there.
Excuse me,
I got caught on that one too.
I actually,
I actually did watch and then what'd they find?
Newspapers or something.
I didn't know that.
Nothing.
Nothing but you,
you're a guy who
is constantly in the outdoors.
You're completely intuned to nature.
You're a conservation issue.
We're very passionate about the outdoors and about hunting and about the
traditions of it and what a discipline it is.
But yet you got sucked into this and I think that this is the same way.
Like if people are starving and all that's on the shelf is some sugary cereal,
you'll have a ball.
That stupid sugary cereal because that's what's there.
But if something else is more interesting and it grab it,
it gets your attention and pulls you into it,
that'll be ultimately much more satisfying.
It's just a matter of not having those options.
And the people that are programming television,
they're just trying to make money.
They're not artists with their,
their goal is to not embarrass themselves.
They don't want to put anything out that shames their family.
They want to put something out that they could say,
Hey,
a storage wars is a good show.
Hey to 100 more episodes of storage work.
And they'll click champagne glasses and they'll drive off in their Mercedes and
they think they're doing a great job.
They're not bad people.
They're just selling something that sells.
They're there,
they're promoting something that they think is going to earn them a living,
living
the a hundred percent I agree.
I mean,
we,
we've done the chips out to New York City and met with these people and,
and you know,
I'm probably burning all kinds of bridges on this,
but you know,
it's mediocrity at its best and then that,
that is what you see and for very good reason,
you know,
the tall poppy,
he's going to get cut off.
So if somebody has the guts to,
to put a show that's actually good that people will watch,
they're going to be the first one to do it.
So they've got to fight against,
imagine that it's not just one box of cereal,
fruit loops and captain crunch on this.
You know,
there is chocolate and nuts and all kinds.
I mean,
it's a,
it's an aisle full of that crop,
that sugary crap and everyone's trying to get the attention of,
now you put one good show in that same mile,
you got everybody addicted to the sugar,
right?
I mean,
once you're eating sugar,
you know,
it's hard to put down a package of Jube use and Twizzlers,
Twizzlers particularly I will eat until the last Twizzlers gone and that,
that's what people will do.
Yeah,
I mean some metaphor,
but that's what they're doing.
They're,
you know,
they're going down that aisle.
There's,
there may be one good show on there,
but you know,
the odds on them,
a biting on or trying it or are really slimmed.
These guys that are making the choice to put that show on that,
on that shelf,
you know,
that guy sitting there with,
with his entire career on the line,
because he tried to do the right thing and to,
to under me down on what's being fed to us on television.
So his mortgage is on the line.
His kids got to go to school,
he's got to have shoes on their feet and now he's done something that's right.
And it doesn't work because there's too much on that shelf over that garbage.
Know there's too many networks.
Everybody's fighting for that,
those eyeballs.
And how does his show stand out?
So he loses his job.
So what do they do?
What,
what,
what do you do?
You put another box of cereal on that,
that shelf of crap and,
and let people eat it.
And,
and that's,
you know,
so like you say there,
it's not their fault.
They're,
they're just,
they're in between a rock and a hard place.
They got to save their,
it's,
it's their income.
And I,
you know,
well,
even the good thing is we have the outdoor channel,
the outdoor channel,
the,
the powers that be at the outdoor channel made the decision to put something
other than crop on the shelves.
And that's why you have uncharted.
I mean,
there are a partner in that show.
They backed it.
They,
they,
uh,
they allowed us to do something that's,
that's you said,
was outside of the genre or beyond the genre that that's what they've done.
So Kudos to them.
I wish that the powers that be in New York City,
on the big networks,
uh,
you know,
the 110 million universe networks had the same guts to do that.
You know,
it's just very difficult to get funding for those kinds of shows.
It's very difficult to get the approval.
You're dealing with a giant conglomeration of human beings.
When you're on NBC or CBS or even a cable network history channel,
you're dealing with a large group of people and there's a lot of money involved
and risk taking is not on the top of their list of priorities.
What's on the top of the list of priorities is how cheap can we do this show?
How many people are going to be reached by the show?
And when you have a show like duck dynasty,
as goofy as that show is,
one of the good things about it is that show reaches millions of people and
millions of people get to see hunting.
And I think that alone,
even if it's not necessarily the most positive show because it is very low brow
and it's very scripted,
it's very obvious.
It's almost insultingly scripted.
Like when you watch it,
you could tell that it's not,
you're not really watching reality,
you know,
they're calling it a reality show.
But all these scenarios are set up in advance.
And I know a lot of people will work in,
in the bay,
like storage wars,
those kinds of shows.
They don't even,
that's not even real.
Like they set those things up,
put those,
there's no way you're going to slag all the other shows,
but it,
you start slagging storage orders.
Well,
the way finding big foot,
big foot for six fucking years now.
They don't find anything on that show that even find skunks.
Yeah.
They find nothing.
That's the same as a ghost show.
I mean,
it's a perfect show to produce because you know,
you know the result every single time.
Yeah.
They actually,
I uh,
they called me in animal planet,
I think it was called me in for a to do a swizzle or something or something.
They call it it to do a on
sign real.
Yeah,
exactly.
To find,
to find big foot.
I didn't know.
I went down and he was like,
okay,
they wanted a hunter.
I,
okay,
I'll go down there.
And he was just,
see what this is all about in the,
I was supposed to be hunting big foot.
It's like,
Oh man,
I see.
Seriously,
Les Stroud,
who's a survivor manager who I loved dearly.
He's a good friend,
a great guy,
but you don't realize how ridiculous the search for big foot is
until you're watching one of those big foot hunter shows with a real hunter.
I was sitting next to Cameron Hanes.
Do you know cam shows very well.
Yeah.
And you know,
Cam Hanes is as legit as it gets.
He's got a good friend of mine and where we're bear hunting up in Canada and
Alberta and we're uh,
in between,
you know,
at night after the Hunt's over,
we're sitting watching television and we're this big
foot show and he's laughing.
He just thinks it's the dumbest thing he's ever seen.
He's just,
they'll what?
Cause the guy that less trout is with is like clearly some sort of a Charlotte,
some sort of a hoaxer and you know,
this guy's got big foot masks on and everything pretended to be big foot.
Like the,
of this crystal clear view of,
of Sasquatch hiding the bushes aren't know if you've seen it,
but it's,
it's so stupid letter strollers,
hosting the show.
Let's tribes a part of it.
And I don't think he buys into this guy either,
but less apparently according to him.
And I believe him.
He's a very,
very honest guy.
Very good guy.
But he had an experience when he was in Alaska.
They flew him into this place to by himself in a,
in a,
in a tent.
And he had this experience of what he believes is a large bipedal animal,
was near his tent and made like an ape,
like noise.
And it freaked him out.
It was many,
many years ago.
He heard like in the middle of the night.
And I'm like,
well,
maybe it was a bear.
I don't mean bears make weird noises.
I don't know what it was.
But he says it was distinctly primate and that when he went for his camera and
started moving and gathering stuff,
it,
it took off.
And he said when it ran off,
it was like,
boom,
boom.
Like a bipedal animal would rather.
Yeah.
I mean,
I've,
uh,
I would never tell this to the public or anything,
but I do have to say that the,
uh,
I was in British Columbia and this was early in my career hunting,
can't remember what I was hunting for Moose or something and,
and uh,
uh,
I heard a sound that absolutely had to be to me an ape.
It was like,
Ooh,
like that,
like,
like loud and clothes.
And then I knew I was only in person in there,
scared the living heck out of me at that time until about 10 years later to
always hid that memory has said you'll find a happy place and keep it
compartmentalize.
I was in British Columbia on a different hunt and I heard the exact same noise
again.
Only this time,
you know it a little bit older,
not,
not quite so self tool to suggestion.
So I snuck up on it.
It was an elk and the elk was doing exactly the [inaudible].
No,
no.
You know,
we like,
I don't go do the whistle.
It was,
it was like,
Ooh,
like that.
Like,
like a a monkey.
I've heard them a million times down in the jungles of West Africa and this was
an elk totally outside of their normal sound range doing sounds that uh,
you know,
if I,
if I didn't know better after 10 years of walking around those monitors and no
one darn well there's nothing in there that the,
the lives on two feet and has a hair all over it other than maybe some of my
guides,
but the,
the uh,
the animal itself was an elk making that noise.
So,
so there's,
you know,
I can't say,
unless this case,
a elk in Alaska don't sound,
it doesn't sound reasonable.
So what that could have been,
I have no idea,
but it could have been a bear making noises outside of it's range.
100% he was in grizzly country also wolverines.
I,
I've
been chased off a mountain one time by a,
a wolverine and that was all night long.
Walked around the tent making crazy ass noises.
That scared the heck out of me then too.
Again,
I'm a little older now.
I don't care as he's,
in fact,
I'm not scared at all anymore.
But,
uh,
you know,
I get concerned sometimes very concerned,
but not,
not freight,
a freight.
They're not frightened,
but that,
that was a,
a wolverine did that.
So same thing,
you know,
it's not normal outside of their normal sound range.
And you know,
when you're on a mountain and,
and you know,
the stars are going in the northern lights and you know,
there's a,
you're the wind and it's a spiritual place in spiritual places is where spirits
live.
So,
you know,
your imagination can run a little wild sometimes,
especially when you're by yourself in a tent.
Uh,
yeah.
By yourself.
Uh,
it's actually worse when you have a hunting partner that's really scared
by yourself,
by yourself.
You've got to deal with things.
When you've got a partner,
you tend to lean on them,
you know,
for help or support.
And if they're even more scared than you are,
then you both just spiraled down into heel.
World's end.
These guys falling in.
Yeah.
This is the other thing that happens with people when it comes to their memories
that memories change over time.
Like I've had conversations with people that about events that we both witnessed
where they have one portrayal of it and have another portrayal of it,
and it's there so different that it's either one of us has lied to ourselves or
over time the retelling of the story has led to the memory getting distorted and
twisted and especially when it comes to the narrative of I was there.
I know big foot is real.
I know it's real.
I saw I was in the woods once and I saw what I thought was a wolf.
It was a squirrel for like two seconds.
I thought it was a wolf wolf.
Yup.
It's a squirrel.
What the fuck is wrong with me?
No,
that can happen easily if you take away all your outside stimulus,
like in the Arctic,
it absolutely hundred percent I've been riding along in a common tech and look
out the side and get all panicky.
There's Grizzy burgers.
They were,
you know,
200 grizzly and all of a sudden I realized,
no,
it's a,
it's a white out.
There's a slope right beside me.
And it's just one of those six hooks,
a little gopher,
and it's 10 feet away.
And you,
you don't,
you don't know.
I mean,
and it's,
thank goodness the Inuit,
if they're open the sled up front,
they can't hear you when you're screaming and cuisine a little,
a little bit embarrassing in that case.
Making fun of the White Man.
Oh yeah.
And those fantasies.
Yeah.
W what do they call this?
A Kabloona big nose.
That's what they call white people were called.
Luna is a,
that means just big nose for whatever reason.
It's interesting.
We let them,
they can say whatever they want.
Uh,
you,
you literally can't make like a bad slang for a white person.
Doesn't exist.
We don't,
you want to call it honkies cause we were so egotistical.
We think,
well that's gotta be a compliment.
Oh,
we're the greatest.
So,
yeah.
Okay.
Just a couple.
Must be,
has to be a compliment.
We're very happy
with being white.
So like whatever you call us,
it just doesn't affect us.
At the end of the day.
We're still white.
Yeah.
They call us a cracker.
You can cause whatever you want.
And we're like,
all right,
this doesn't,
you know,
like an insult for an African American or for a Chinese person or what,
fill in the blank.
He's,
he's like very devastating,
horrible racial slur.
But an insult for a white person.
He's like,
yeah,
I mean that doesn't work.
I mean,
I can't speak for all white people,
but for me,
I'm willing to speak for all white people.
Cause there's a white person out there that does get offended by any sort of a
slur towards white people.
They don't deserve to be white.
How about that?
I'm saying it said by Joe Rogan,
I said,
I said it,
you don't deserve.
You got lucky.
You're born white.
It's like the most acceptable like minority or it's almost a minority now.
Right.
It's getting to the point where in 2000 and it said that in America,
within the next,
uh,
I think it's two or three decades being in Caucasian will actually be a
minority.
Oh,
I'm sure.
I mean,
you know,
and if you look at,
if you look at that historically,
I mean,
and again this is,
you know,
so unscientific,
but,
but you know,
maybe our role was to explore and discover new places and colonize.
And then who comes after?
I mean there's always an after.
Who is it?
You know,
like you go to Africa right now and you know,
it's wonderful being a white person,
but there's parts Africa that is not quite so great and,
but what you do find is tons and tons of Chinese people.
They're there,
they're in Africa,
they're colonizing Africa.
How of the resources.
Resources.
Yeah.
And,
and it's,
you know,
we are,
again,
this is one of those times when I sit on my little mountain top and look out
with and feel despair.
Um,
you know,
the,
these,
the entire continent,
continent of Africa is being colonized by,
by the Chinese.
Uh,
and it'll be a different,
it'll be a different roadmap in 20 years.
30 years.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's amazing.
So Amy,
you know,
when we may well be knocked off our,
or our pedestals here in the next couple of minutes,
even if we are,
we'll still be so super,
I still be you or any white slur that you throw our way.
We'll just still take it as a couple.
And I were like,
fine,
whatever you want to call us,
we're still white.
That's true.
I think the most egotistical raise ever to white folks.
But it's interesting that you brought that up because,
um,
in,
in a related point when you're talking about,
you know,
what comes next and people exploring.
And I think that what I was saying earlier about the age of information and
that,
um,
one of the things that's changing because you've got these reality shows on and
all these is goofy programming,
this sugar programming that you're getting on television because of the age of
information that we live in.
There's all these alternatives now on the Internet.
I mean you have like these,
uh,
things like Netflix,
which has I think something like 60 million subscribers that pay $7 a month.
They have so much,
they are producing their own original
programming now and they have this show called house of cards.
It's a fantastic show.
They're doing talk shows.
I've got to Chelsea handler talk show that they're doing,
they're doing stand up comedy specials.
They're doing all these different things because they have all this money now,
but they're taking all these wild chances and they're doing this really
interesting out of the box stuff.
And then you have things like podcasts,
things like this where we don't really have a boss,
we don't have anybody to tell us what to do.
So we could have a guy like you want to,
I,
anybody I have on this show is only anybody.
I'm interested.
I'll take that as a company.
I'm a huge fan of yours.
You should definitely take it as a compliment.
But this,
this,
this sugar diet is not necessary anymore.
Now this is a part of what's happening,
this rapid change that's happening in our culture.
And when,
one of the things that I think a backlash against hunting is that people are
hoping that we're going to separate from what we were,
what took what we,
we we went through to get us here and what we went through to get us here is all
the brutality that we know that happened with the native Americans and all the,
you know,
the idea that they were almost wiped off the buffalo wipe,
the buffalo off the face of the planet and that people had to hunt for a living
to feed their families.
They had to go out and be barbaric and that this age of information and that
this,
this change is evolutionary change is going on in our culture is eventually
going to lead us away from a diet of eating meat.
And I think that's something that people,
that's one of the reasons why people have this sort of rejection of hunting.
That's this,
this idea that they have in their head is at this is the remnants are the echoes
of a barbaric past.
And when you see these people understanding with a,
you know,
a rifle on top of a lion like Ernest Hemingway,
and instead of that,
it's that cute girl.
I don't know what her name is that was involved in that huge Facebook
controversy because she had Kendall Kendall.
Yes.
Yup.
And it's along the same lines.
It's like we're trying to get away from that old way and embrace some sort of a
new way.
Yeah,
it's a new messiah.
I mean that,
that's,
that's what they're looking at as opposed to looking at the real picture,
which is how many millions of years,
depending on what you believe in.
Have we been doing the same thing?
We're not going to change it.
I use an analogy,
you know,
two dinosaurs standing there.
You'll,
one has three toes on,
one has four toes,
and the one with three toes.
He's highly of all because he's got three toes and he's laughing at the other
one.
You know,
you got four toes.
I got three toes.
I'm,
I'm evolved.
And when the comment strikes,
it doesn't matter how many tools you have,
you are still a dinosaur.
You're a dinosaur and this is what people are trying to do.
They're trying to ignore what brought them to the,
to the dance,
you know,
like you said it,
the,
the hunting brought us here.
We've been hunting cultures up until 10,000 years ago when we turned agrarian.
And even then,
some of us still stayed as a hunting,
you know,
there's a percentage have that gene where the hunters were the better hunters in
the tribe back then were,
we're still hunters.
You can't get rid of that in 10,000 years.
Doesn't happen.
So they're trying to,
trying to,
like you say,
ignore the fact that all of us are here because of hunting and you want to
change because you think what you eat soy means,
I mean,
give me a break,
you know,
go look that soybean field,
how many,
how many acres of that soybean field is actual ecosystem where wildlife can
live.
You know,
someone that says I'm a Vegan or Vegan or whatever they call themselves and you
know,
they can punch his pilot.
I don't hurt animals.
Look at the soybean field.
You killed.
How many animals in that field because you had to survive with your soybeans.
That's,
that's,
there's no way you can separate us,
you know,
and,
uh,
you know,
no matter how much information is out there and how stair you want to make this,
say,
we don't eat meat,
there's no way you can separate the fact that all of us,
we're carnivores or omnivores at the very least,
and all of us got here were around today because of hunting.
And,
and it's,
it's not a tradition.
It's not a skill.
It's not a lifestyle that's going to go anywhere.
In fact,
I suspect,
you know,
when that comment does hit that that's who I'll still be around,
soybean fields,
you know,
pretty common does hit,
I hope it hits me right in the head.
I don't want to live some strain,
post apocalypse,
Mad Max world.
You may not want to live like that,
but,
but guess who's going to survive in that suit?
Of course,
the people who know how to actually live.
Yeah.
And I,
and I'm not,
I'm not predicting that anyway.
You know,
I'm certainly not saying that.
This is what's going to happen.
Well,
it's fascinating to me that there's so much backlash against hunters and someone
posing with an animal that they shot get so much backlash.
Yet you can have an advertisement of a guy eating a Carl's junior cheeseburger
with a big smile on his face and nobody thinks it's offensive.
Nobody has any problem with it.
One of the,
I shot a bear and there's a picture of me and Cameron Hanes and I hate that
bear.
By the way,
me and Cameron Hanes standing over this bear and we're both smiling and people
were angry.
They were saying you,
this should be a somber moment like you're smiling,
but this should be a somber moment.
Says,
who is it?
If I was eating a cheeseburger and smiling,
would anybody really have a problem with it?
You go down any road in America and Canada as well and pass by in any town where
their stoplights and stores,
you're going to find dead animals all over the place.
You're going to find dead animals that are on people's cars in the,
in their,
in their seats.
You're going to find it on their feet,
you're going to find it in all the restaurants you see.
99 plus percent of all restaurants serve some form of animal protein.
Everywhere you go,
you're seeing dead animals.
And we conveniently ignore that and focus on what we think is in our cake
practice.
The practice of going into the wild and killing the animal.
Yeah.
Yourself
know,
to there,
to there in their defense when they see us smiling over a dead animal.
And this is something that I've,
you know,
I have to reconcile it,
inside myself.
Why,
you know,
why,
what bothers them about it?
Well,
it looks like you took joy in,
in the actual death of the animal.
Yes.
But that's not what you took joy yet.
And that's not what you're smiling.
You're smiling about the accomplishment,
the fact that you met the challenge as great as it may be,
and they don't understand that people looking at the picture,
how great that challenge is to get that bare,
you know,
the skills that it took for you to get,
I think he used a bow and arrow.
Yeah.
And I mean,
just go try and learn a bone Arrow first then talk to me about,
you know,
the challenge of getting that bear,
a wild animal that's switched on,
tuned in.
It's his backyard and you're in there trying to hunt him and he's,
if he's true to what his nature is,
is his nature is to try and avoid being hunted.
Whether it's by another bear for interspecies predation or whether it's a hunter
human hunter,
maybe it's walls coming in to kill him or a cougar who knows what's trying to
kill him.
His,
his job is to survive.
So you're going in there with a bone Arrow to hunt that animal and it worked.
It's a huge challenge that you met and challenge.
The accomplishment is directly proportional to the challenge.
You met it.
Why wouldn't you smile?
Why wouldn't you be,
you know,
paying homage to that,
that hunt for that animal and,
and be proud of it and be smiling and,
and I think this is where the disconnect is for people looking at it.
You know,
they see a picture of,
of like my daughter with her bare smiling and they go,
how can you do that at the pictures?
What offends those people?
Because they equate the smiling with a joy of killing the animal.
That's not what hunting's about that.
That's a necessary part to have hunted.
In fact it was or take it to gas at the Spanish philosopher said that,
you know,
I don't hunt to kill,
I kill to have hunted.
So you have to eventually kill something to actually be hunting.
If you're taking photographs,
you didn't hunt what you were a boy year.
You,
you weren't part of nature,
you were just there.
And,
and no offense to all the photographers out there,
cause I'm sure in a lot of ways it's like hunting and for them that capturing or
the animal is,
is,
is like capturing of the animal.
But you know what?
It doesn't taste good.
I don't care.
I don't care how you prepare.
That picture is not going to taste like you're your bear roaster or whatever you
did.
It made sausages with it.
And I think that the pictures,
you know,
that the people that don't hunt and maybe sitting on the fence about hunting or,
or anti hunters for sure they don't,
they equate the smile with the joy of killing and,
and that's,
that's not what it is.
That's not what it's about.
And,
and I,
you know,
again,
that's,
that's us,
I guess educating.
We haven't done a great job.
We haven't had the tools to do it until now,
until now.
I know what it is,
is people just haven't had a guy like you explain it that way.
They just see that image and they draw their own conclusions based on our
culture,
based on our culture of being able to go to the supermarket,
pick up a piece of meat,
pay for it with a credit card and you're done.
And this complete disconnect.
And now you see a guy smiling,
standing over a dead animal.
Meanwhile,
these people,
I had a guy come up to me in the airport,
I've talked about this on the podcast before,
but he was upset that I a bear.
He's like,
I can't believe he killed a bear.
I go,
you're wearing leather shoes,
you're wearing leather.
What do the fuck are you talking about?
I ate that bear.
You're wearing leather shoes,
man.
You don't even know where that shoe came from.
You don't know that cow.
You don't know anything about how it was acquired.
You're eating meat probably on a daily basis,
and if you're not eating meat and you're wearing leather shoes,
either it's for health purposes or you're a silly person.
Yeah.
They don't want to know the truth.
I mean,
they don't want to know that that cow that they're eating,
which is an hammered reform,
it wrapped in cellophane.
They don't want to know about the life of that cow,
that they want to keep that like insulated.
They want to,
you know,
coordinate off and I,
oh,
I say it is,
it's like the truth sometimes is like laying on cold hard ground.
It's not fun.
It's cold.
It's hard and you try and sleep when they're gone.
It's just,
but it's the truth.
It's the reality.
It's the truth.
Many,
many people in our culture nowadays or are they,
they build a house of,
of an ideology.
They build a house.
It's just like a castle.
Elliot protects them and from the truth and they then they make a bed of,
of,
of hypocrisy,
you know,
and the wear leather,
they eat meat,
but they don't wanna know the truth out there.
That animal,
how it lived.
Then they cover themself in a,
in a comforter of denial.
They wanted to deny that they had anything to do with that.
You know,
punches probably at washed her hands.
Don't,
I don't want to hit,
I don't want to see it.
Don't want to hear it.
The cold,
hard truth,
it means lying on the ground sometimes and they live inside these,
these castles,
these ideological castles that they,
it just,
it,
it would destroy their world to realize that that person that took you to task
for killing that beer and eating it actually is wearing a killed animal and eats
animals and they had a horrible life,
which is a better life that bear that lived till whatever it was.
You know?
I know,
I saw the picture is probably uh,
you know,
six,
seven,
eight year old boar,
you know,
probably pass breeding age.
This animal lived,
hits life wild and free and then one arrow came out of the blue because it made
one mistake and walked in when it shouldn't have walked in.
Its senses weren't switched on as much as they should have been to ensure that
that animal passes it's jeans on for generations to come and it's dead.
The cow,
the deck is eating,
thinking well that life in a feed pan being shot full of every describable
antibiotic and you know,
sprayed with any pesticides,
living with no space.
What kind of life is that?
And that person has the right to come to you and take you to task for killing a
wild animal that lived wild and free and had every chance to walk away but
didn't.
And in fact,
you know,
if you,
if you believe in Darwin,
it was probably a good thing you shot it.
You know,
no offense to you and you and a camera.
I mean,
it had to be a pretty dumb bear to walk in,
you know,
so.
So is that a very you on passing on his jeans?
Right,
right,
right.
Well,
I think that in in the defense of the people who get angry and they're not,
they're just not getting the information.
They're just not,
there's no,
the dean of the information is not being representative by our culture.
And that's why they have these ideas.
That's why they have these childish notions.
Well,
you're talking about the cold,
hard truth.
You live in the cold,
hard truth,
but it's not ugly.
It's not nasty.
I've been living in the cold hard truth for the past couple of years since I
started hunting.
It's not bad.
I just shot a moose last weekend.
It was great.
Had a great time.
Congratulations.
Yeah,
I mean people want,
don't want to hear that you shot a moose.
He had a great time.
I had a great time.
It was a hard hunt.
We hunted for four days climbing up hills,
sneaking up on moves that winded us and they took off and there was a lot going
on.
It was day after day of struggling.
It's very difficult to shoot.
A Moose is difficult to acquire or you get lucky and one can just,
you know,
in the Rut could walk right in front of you and you blasted when that's possible
too.
But,
and in our situation it was a long and difficult time.
So when we finally did get this animal,
it was very exciting.
It was very exciting.
It was a very happy moment.
But most people don't experience that.
And what we're talking about when you say that people don't live in the truth,
they don't have the opportunity,
they,
they don't urinate all the time.
I've been in it over the last couple of years,
but it's not,
I don't believe it's their fault.
I think it's our culture is filled with these infant tile notions of like what's
acceptable,
what's not acceptable,
what,
what?
What should we lau,
which should we not allow me?
We're constantly adding new words to the words that we're not allowed to say
anymore.
We're constantly changing our,
our,
our stances on,
on all sorts of behavior that was normally accepted and we're becoming more and
more hypersensitive.
And I think one of the reasons why we're so hypersensitive because we're fucking
babies,
were a bunch of babies were babies that are coddled and we have this really
soft,
easy life who we hop in metal boxes with a rubber tires and we ride over this
hard surface everywhere.
We sit into his cubicle and we live this life of zero threat of zero challenge
of zero risk.
The only risk is that they might take away your cubicle.
Oh No,
how will I be able to stuffed myself full of sugar cereal?
I can't sit at this stupid fucking cubicle anymore.
That's our main risk in this life outside of car accidents and disease,
which by the way,
the car accidents are caused because you have to get to this stupid fucking
cubicle.
The diseases are caused by the Diet that you're eating is terrible.
Diet is responsible for a large majority of the diseases that people have in
this world.
A large,
I mean,
outside of viral illnesses,
of course a lot of the problems that we have in this country deal with obesity,
poor diet,
massive sugar intake,
cholesterol is all sorts of shit that people put into their bodies today.
That's absolutely terrible and it's all a part,
it's a symptom of the same thing of this,
this w this infant tile society that we live in.
There's no risks.
We're trying,
we're trying to regulate out all objective dangers.
Yes.
And soon as you do
that,
what,
what have,
what have you created a society of people that are unable to adapt,
unable to respond to a new novel situation.
And you know,
when you bring in the Diet,
they're unable to fight off whatever diseases are out there.
I mean,
God forbid that there's,
you know,
we get hit by a real bad pandemic of whatever because we're not going to be able
to fight it off if we don't have the drugs.
We don't have the resistance.
Now you want to see resistance,
just go over to these Asian countries,
go over to Africa and South America and in those people are tough.
You know,
and really,
I mean,
we shouldn't be the sugar,
get rid of the sugar diets and go eat a more panty worm.
You know,
like they can expand your,
what you ingest because that's going to give you resistance to all of these
various strains of whatever.
I mean,
it's a,
I mean this,
when I was saying is it's not terrible.
Our society's not 100% awful and we still create great art.
We still have these incredible technological achievements that are fascinating
and interesting.
Our education system is better than it's ever been before as far as the acts and
shouldn't say system,
but our access to information,
it's better than it's ever been before.
So there's all sorts of great things about living in a civilized society that I
appreciate except to take,
you know,
take part of,
I think there's,
it's,
it's not universally bad,
but what is missing is a connection with all the other animals that are on this
planet.
It connection with the cycle of life.
And that's something that I think people rejecting when they reject hunting.
They're rejecting this idea that we are a part of that,
that we are a part of the cycle of life,
that we've moved past that we've moved past that I've had to pay people tale.
Tell me why would you go hunting when you buy meat at a store you just go to a
store.
I've met people that,
I know they're are smart but they just,
they haven't been exposed to it.
They haven't thought about it.
This is almost a new concept to them.
They have this peripheral thinking when it comes to where the meat comes from
and if you show any interest whatsoever and being more involved in it and
participating in it and a much deeper level of specialty actually going out into
the woods and calling it an elk and trying to shoot an arrow through its lungs
and like what the fuck is wrong with you?
Like why would you do that?
Why do you want to do that?
Yeah.
The old and again it's a denial.
They're denying that we are part of nature.
I mean we,
we are instruments of nature's change.
That's what we are,
but we are still part of nature,
whatever.
Again,
this is looking from the big picture where this biomass on this planet,
it's changed from dinosaurs.
Now it's a lot of it is us and whatever we create,
but it's,
it's still there in the same,
the same amount is still there.
So it's just change form and if they think they're not part of that,
there are somehow above and aloof from it.
I mean,
and again,
I,
you know,
I watch television and,
which isn't a lot,
but if I do see it in,
I see the nature shows,
you're always,
you're,
it's the animal,
a boy you're looking in at it.
So they,
they perpetrate that are perpetuated that,
that,
that image that we're separated from wildlife.
We're not looked at that lion killing the whatever,
Cape Buffalo.
We would never do that because we just watched and we observe and look in the
lower life forms.
That's not what it's about.
We are those life forms.
We're,
we're part of nature.
And you just have to get out of your,
like you say,
your cubicle,
not,
I won't describe the same way you did,
but the cubicle you get out of it going into the world.
And you'll see,
I mean,
everywhere around this world,
we are part of nature and unfortunately we're,
we're,
um,
we're an ugly part of it right now.
If,
if you're concerned about wildlife because we're pushing back these animals into
these tiny little enclaves and they're fighting for their survival.
Well,
I had this conversation recently with someone online who was telling me,
you know,
hey man,
your ideas about animals are ridiculous.
You know,
the,
those bears,
the reason why those bears are pushing into this New Jersey suburb was cause
people are pushing it to the,
now that's not true.
There's,
there's an overpopulation of them and it's not good for the bears.
There's more bears per capita or per square mile in New Jersey than anywhere
else in North America.
That's crazy.
The fact that you've got a place like New Jersey,
that's,
you know,
you think about New Jersey,
you think,
uh,
Joe Piscopo from Saturday night live.
You think of,
you know,
you think of Frank Sinatra and Jon Bon Jovi and Bruce Springsteen.
You don't think of fucking bears.
Let me,
while a kid from Rutgers last month got killed by a black bear,
and the reason is there,
there,
there are too many of them.
They're starving.
And that's why you see that,
that battle.
Well,
those two big black bears were duking it out in that New Jersey suburb.
I mean,
that's Rutherford,
New Jersey,
that's like,
might as well be here in Canoga Park.
It's just,
it's a normal American suburb and you got seven foot black bears,
Duke it out on the streets,
big 300 pound bear's going to war with each other.
That has to be taken care of.
If you want a Pete,
if you want to have people,
if people want to live in those environments,
you have to regulate and control those populations.
And that's something that people don't want to see.
They don't want to think of it that way.
They want to think that somehow another nature's just going to sort it all out.
Nature of just leave nature on its own guests.
What you're a part of nature.
That's what people don't.
Yeah,
it,
we'll sort it out,
but it might mean they eat us.
That is a possibility.
And that's what people don't want to consider when they think about nature.
Sorting it up.
Nature sorts it out.
Meaning if you have too much of one thing in,
in an area,
yeah,
it does it achieve some sort of a balance.
But along the way you might lose some kids.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
again,
we're,
we're so removed and it's,
the problem with the whole thing from a hunter's perspective is the wildlife
loses that battle 100% of the time.
They,
you know,
we push,
we pushed them back because w there's too,
there's too many people,
so they have less area to live.
So they pushed back.
When we get more numbers,
they come into our suburbs and you saw the bears battling,
but it's a,
hey,
you know,
we,
we can't,
we hunters want more animals,
but we also want to be able to control the numbers.
We're realists again,
the cold,
hard truth,
they have to be killed.
Now that you can do it two different ways.
You,
and this is again,
you know I've seen this before where people somehow don't have a problem with,
with euthanization,
right?
They hire a,
a mercenary shooter who has no feeling for those animals.
That's just,
it's just a target and he'll go in there at night with a silencer and pop off
the bears and kill a bunch of them.
I guess what people don't want to see is that hunters go in there and in some
way are enjoying themselves on this hunt and there again,
this is that,
that disconnect.
They don't realize the challenge.
It's not so simple to just go with their simpler to go up there and pop them off
at night with,
with a night vision scope.
When a silencer,
you can do that easily,
you know,
and you do kill them and,
and they're gone.
But,
but you know,
to me that's,
that's treating them like a,
with such disrespect.
I mean these are wild animals that,
that were,
their entire being is to survive and to live through hunters trying to kill him,
not,
not to pop them off with a,
you know,
with a sniper scope at night.
So again,
this is a battle that US hunters have to fight and fight it well because we will
lose that.
They want to euthanize.
It's okay to kill how many,
how many dogs and cats get put down every single day.
Right,
right around here.
Dogs and cats get put down by Peta that some people don't want to listen to.
That's the Beta is responsible for the death of a large number.
Of course they can't take care of,
but somehow in people's mind,
that's okay.
That's okay.
Yeah.
And it's a,
it's a weird thing.
And again,
it goes back to the picture of the smiling hunter over the animal,
or you enjoyed the death of that animal that's sick.
It's also ignorant in the form of they don't understand that the money that goes
to hunting tags and to where when you pay for,
for to hunt,
when you,
when you buy a hunting tag,
that money directly goes into the fish and wildlife departments and the fish and
wildlife departments hire biologists to,
they don't,
they're not like putting hunts out because people say,
well,
we weren't to hunt the animals.
We don't care how many of them they are.
No.
The fish and wildlife department,
they tell you how many animals can be taken.
They release a certain amount of tags and dependent upon the area.
If you can have some areas where they have unlimited tags because there's too
many animals,
they're trying to thin the herd or you have animals like you know like a big
horn sheep in Montana,
very difficult to get a tag for it.
It's hard to draw because they're trying to build the numbers out in Nevada,
same situation.
They're trying to build the numbers up.
Very difficult to get a tag for.
These are all done by biologists,
and the money that comes from hunting them goes directly into conservation.
That money is exactly the opposite of what happens if you have to go in and hire
somebody to kill them on a sniper rifle.
Because if you have,
if you have to hire someone to thin the herd,
the herds out you have to that guy.
So the money that would have come from the conservation,
from the hunting tags,
it's not there anymore.
And now instead you're,
you're in a deficit because you have to actually use public funds to go in there
and eliminate those animals.
So instead of those animals being a valuable resource,
now those animals,
it's a,
it's an issue where you have to actually pay for it,
the taxpayers.
But the bill,
here's a,
here's another little side angle on that one.
When hunters pay for their licenses,
when they,
they bring an economic value to that community,
that area where those animals live,
the animals are suddenly empowered with,
with,
with money,
they have value.
Now you can actually those animals in,
in one way.
I mean,
it's a,
again,
a strange,
uh,
is difficult for people to understand this,
but it's the,
you give the,
you hunt the animals,
they essentially have value and they have,
if they have a surplus of that value,
they can start to buy back habitat,
right?
I mean,
all the CPR,
was it what you guys call CWP lands or whatever they are.
Our WP lands where they're,
they're,
they're farmers are allowed to put their land back into natural habitat.
That's wildlife buying back that land.
So,
so not only are you bye bye.
Sniping them off.
What have you done?
You've killed them for predation.
Depredation on the crops.
Okay,
great.
I get it.
What value to the animal health?
No,
you're just going to keep killing them.
And if the crops keep pushing into the,
where the animals live,
you're going to kill them all.
I mean,
we did it with the Bison.
Virtually.
We killed down to 500 of them.
That's if you give those animals money when witch hunters do it,
you know it's,
you know,
it's a,
it's a hard,
you know,
hard to grasp because it's,
it doesn't make sense.
But you give those animals money,
they buy back the habitat.
You hunter kills one animal,
but the animal is buy back 10 more acres,
which means two animals live,
you know,
and,
and a bigger picture,
they buy back hundreds of thousands of acres like in places in Africa where it's
only hunting that has kept those animals alive without hunting.
They are gone.
And they're the buffer zone between the parks and,
and the great massive crush of humanity coming in towards the parks.
The hunting dollars protects those animals that animals have bought back their
land,
literally bought it back.
The hunters pay hundreds of thousands of dollars,
millions of dollars to go hunt there,
that communities get the money.
So they said,
okay,
we'll protect the animals will protect them because we're getting more money
from that.
That killing these animals for $5 on Bushmeat and,
and over here.
Yes,
it's,
you know,
we may be more sophisticated,
but the problem is still there.
You know,
the bears in North Carolina,
if the hunters,
they might be losing $60,000 in,
in one,
three or 400 acre crop field,
you know,
$60,000 in,
in crop depredation from the,
from the bears.
They get zero money for those bears.
What do you think that they're gonna do?
They're gonna shoot,
shovel and shut up the animals.
The bears will be gone.
Now when the hunter comes in and pays x amount of dollars,
suddenly the farmer and they,
and they don't want to kill the bears,
you know,
they're,
they're sent here in human beings.
They,
they,
they know what they're doing.
They don't want to kill him and bury them.
So now they're,
they have a reason they're there.
They're grasping for it there.
They're begging for it.
Give us money for these animals and we will then protect animals.
I'll let them meet my $60,000 in corn crop.
So the hunters are not just,
you know,
working as a conservation tool to,
buffer.
These,
protect these animals from coming into our communities.
They're also empowering the animals to buy back their,
their lives.
They're there giving them value and nothing is going to survive the next,
I'd say 30 years,
nothing,
no wildlife,
no tree,
nothing in this planet will survive the next 30 years unless it has value.
They have to be able to pay their way.
In today's world,
I don't like the spotted owl when they shut down logging.
Same thing the spotted owl.
When,
when push comes to shove,
when this world gets really cranked up,
they're going to cut down those trees,
you know,
down the marbled Murrelet it's going down because the trees coming down.
But if the Marble Mule let,
for whatever reason,
can pay for those trees to stand up,
which know they tried to do,
uh,
you know,
I mean the big fight back in that was like an eighties or nineties fight.
You know,
they did protect some of the habitat back then.
But when,
when it gets really dire and we realize we're in a fight with the rest of the
world,
the competition around this world for resources is going to be so huge and so
expensive.
You know when your house costs you $20 million to build because there's no wood,
you know you're going to cut down the trees that you have access to and you know
down the marble and mule led,
it's going down on that tree.
So,
so these animals,
if there's a way for them to pay,
then they have to pay.
Now as hunters,
we can't fight the marble mural letter,
the spotter dollars flight.
We can't fight that.
But we can fight the battle for the bigger game like the,
I mean all the way up from prairie dogs to Moose and in North America,
we can fight for them on their behalf.
We can,
we can finance them to buy back their existence to protect their existence.
Isn't that such a bizarre contradiction?
And this is one of the things that people have such a hard time grasping.
The idea that somehow or another you killing those animals is good for those
animals.
Yeah.
It doesn't make sense.
What,
what's the word?
I've been trying to think of what my brain,
I've gone brain dead.
It's a contradictory then I know there's another oxymoron.
Oxymoron.
Yeah.
Jumbo shrimp.
Military Intelligence.
It doesn't,
it doesn't make sense.
Yeah.
It's,
it's indicative of like how bizarre life really,
truly is and also how bizarre life truly really is.
When we're disconnected from the information that,
that we really should have access to when it comes to like where our food comes
from,
that we are actually animals,
that we are actually a part of this cycle of life.
That we are actually in Greece,
we,
we've done this strange thing by putting ourselves in these big cement boxes and
buildings and pave the roads and locked ourselves and put bolts on the doors.
We've separated ourselves from our environment in such a profound way that we
don't think that we're a part of it anymore until you're forced to be out naked
and afraid.
You know,
those,
those silly shows,
they make people go out into the wild and you realized like,
wow,
we're,
we're so fucking vulnerable.
We're unbelievably vulnerable.
If you take away our buildings and you take away our cars.
And especially if you take away our clothes,
we truly are just a life form.
We just a weird,
bizarre life form.
It's figured out how to wait to make clothes and shoes and houses and all these
different things.
But we want to think of ourselves as being alien.
We want to think of ourselves as being separate from it.
Yeah.
But we're not,
we're not and,
and you know,
and to be fair,
not everybody lives like that.
You know,
not everybody does,
but there's a deal with urbanization over the last,
whatever,
starting in the 50s forties 50s you know,
we have gone that route,
but not everybody.
It's a recent thing.
Yeah.
And it's not everybody,
like you can still go out into Wyoming and find people.
Alaska.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
look at the everybody up there and even northern California,
you know,
there's still people,
lots of them.
There's lots of us that are still out there that aren't buying in.
You know,
we're not,
we're not drinking that Koolaid.
Uh,
we'll,
we'll take advantage of,
of the,
uh,
the modern technologies.
I mean,
you know,
Internet's great.
We can tweet and Facebook and do all that kind of thing,
but we can also be in touch with nature.
We can be true to who we are as human beings.
I thought it was really fascinating,
one of your shows to get back to uncharted.
It was amazing.
You were in Pakistan and you were putting something up on Facebook and the
negative comments of people that had this very ignorant idea.
And when I say ignorant,
it's based not on any information that they've gotten firsthand.
It's based only on the propaganda of Pakistan has nuclear weapons.
It's a Muslim country.
They're going to go to war with India.
They harbored terrorism.
They have all the,
we have all these ideas that we have been fed.
And meanwhile,
you're over there with these people.
You're breaking bread with these people.
You're sitting around a fire with these people and you're,
you're posting these,
uh,
updates of your,
your hunting experience on Facebook and these people are making these comments.
He's super negative comments.
And because of that you had to actually get out of town.
Yeah.
You know,
that's not everybody over there is a good guy.
that,
that's,
that's just face it.
That's the reality.
But that's like not everybody hears exactly right.
Not Everybody on this planet,
I don't care where you touched down on is a good guy and I use that figuratively
there.
There's bad people over there.
And when you,
when you,
uh,
the,
that particular situation,
I actually had to cut out a lot of,
a lot of what we videoed because people would get hurt if I hear that.
But I'll get,
I'll,
I'll give you a quick sort of idea of what could happen in a place like that.
Uh,
it,
you know,
where there's people that are,
are monitoring Facebook pages.
There's,
there's political party that wants change in democracy and they're the good
guys.
Then there's military powers that want to take overs,
basically dictate to the people and in those countries that that's a volatile
changing,
evolving dynamic situation.
Now the military has access to the,
uh,
like you have the CIA,
so they have their secret service or their intelligence agencies that are second
only to Israeli or Israel because of their,
their,
uh,
the money that was pumped into their,
through the 1980s,
you know,
the 1990s,
the money came in by the billions of dollars.
These guys are very capable.
So the military runs the,
the,
the intelligence agencies,
the intelligence age,
she's monitor everything.
What happens is the,
this is where it gets a little complicated.
If somebody was with somebody who's maybe associated with government and
democracy and you know,
the good guys,
they would,
well,
I'm never going to get back into this country if I,
if I go too far down this line.
But,
but they just say for instance,
the intelligence agency could,
could do something that would cause the political side of things,
the good guys to get an egg on their face.
Like,
say somebody who was kidnapped,
that was a,
you know,
a known entity over here in North America,
that person would be,
you know,
family.
It's a terrible thing for that to happen.
So if the intelligence agency knows what's going on and they happen to slip that
word too,
the real bad guys.
Right?
And those,
those are just the thugs.
The criminals are gangsters.
If they slipped that information to them,
they would love nothing more than to,
you know,
cause anarchy.
They don't care who it is.
So,
so that's what happened.
We got to,
we got a,
a word that we had 15 minutes,
get out of there now.
Right now.
Go and,
and you know,
do not take any of the roads you've traveled on.
You,
you know,
it's,
the word's been given out to the bad guy.
So we actually had to go and that,
that's,
you know,
I didn't know what was going on at that point.
I was going,
what's awesome action,
action and uh,
and we're on the road.
No sirens going and getting the heck out of dodge.
Well,
that was,
that was what that was about.
And I couldn't air that,
I couldn't show that because it would have caused people to be in trouble.
Who phoned?
Who warned who?
You know,
it brings up too many questions and like I say,
I'm hoping I'm not causing anybody in trouble right now.
I don't think so.
Or Pre being pretty vague about it.
So I think the visual depictions of,
you know,
you interacting with those guys would probably be much more problematic I would
guess.
But so they would,
you,
you could be used as almost like a political tool.
That's all you are.
That's all your and,
and your nothing in this world that when those guys could care less right there,
there,
I mean there'd be hitting guys right now.
Uh,
it's,
it's just your,
you know,
nothing personal,
but we're going to be heads you because this is going to get us press and that's
what we need,
right?
Like all these journalists that they keep sending over that thing out,
putting them on video,
you're still putting yourself in those situations though,
and you're doing it to film the show and your deal.
I mean,
you could easily go to Nebraska and go big buck hunting and some cornfield and
you know,
and you could probably have a really interesting show,
but instead you're choosing to go halfway around the world to one of the most
dangerous volatile areas currently and on an animal.
And do it as the hunting the animals,
like a task that you have to do on this show.
The actual show itself is more about you interacting with the culture and you
getting this,
this very unique sense of who these people are and what their lives are like.
Yeah.
I don't know that there's any other way you could do it.
I mean that in every society in this world,
there's hunters.
They are there,
no denying it.
There's 10% of the population are hunters.
And that's probably historic.
Uh,
it goes back into prehistoric times.
Actually,
you know,
a percentage of the population was that were the hunters and a percentage where
the basket makers,
I mean,
someone had to do both.
Right?
So,
you know,
for,
for me,
I go to these countries to find those hunters.
And once you're embedded with them living like they do with them doing what they
do every day,
you are so far away from the tourist lanes,
you know,
the,
the photography photo op places,
busloads or,
or even individuals going,
even our journalists,
you know,
there's very few there.
They're being fed,
whatever,
they're being fed.
When we're with the hunters in that community,
we literally are being swallowed up and integrated into that community.
And that's what we try and do is live with the hunters learned from the hunters.
And that gives us an insight into their,
these societies all around the world that you can't get any other way.
I don't believe you can.
And you maybe Jane Goodall argue with me when she goes in there that she's,
you know,
she's embedding herself and,
and,
and she's part of their cultures and she probably is.
But hunting is,
is definitely a way to do it.
I mean,
Marco Polo is a hunter.
All the great explorers were hunters.
That's how they,
that's how they fed themselves on these trips.
Everyone Shackleton named,
named them,
named Lewis and Clark,
all of them,
they hunted to survive while they explored.
And for me,
you know,
uncharted is,
is,
you know,
you said I was there to film the show.
That's not really what I'm doing.
I'm there to just be who I am and to do what I do with the shows,
documenting what I do.
If there was no camera with me,
I would still be in there.
You know,
for your own personal,
of course,
of course.
I want to know,
I want to experience.
And I also,
you know,
I said at the beginning,
I don't feel fear.
I id test when,
when somebody tries to instill that feeling in me,
they tried to terrorize me.
I,
it just drives me wild to the point where,
okay,
now here we are now mano a Mano and you,
you tell me,
go ahead.
You know,
I'm facing,
you know,
this is not an unknown,
lurking dark fear.
That whole side of the world is a scary place.
No,
I'm right here.
You know,
and what you find most times is that our press tends to,
uh,
you know,
they,
they tend to feed us propaganda and people in all of these places,
the vast majority are good people.
Now they may believe in a totally different construct than we do religiously.
Politically.
It just civilly,
they may be in like unfathomable to us.
We look at and go,
you gotta be kidding me.
You know,
you say you own your wife like,
like you are one confused guy.
But that's if we're judging them,
if we're just there going,
okay,
you know,
that's what they believe.
But they're good people.
They just have a,
you know,
different than us.
So,
so that what I found traveling into these places,
and again,
it's just to affirm,
I think partially inside myself that the vast majority of this world is filled
with good people,
good people that,
you know,
they have children,
they laughed,
they raise them with love.
They may have the weirdest,
you know,
the two wives have 10 wives or whatever.
That stuff.
I don't get the,
you know,
they may eat stuff that I just look and go,
well,
it's not really for me,
but hey,
you know,
that's good for them.
And the hunting allows me to go inside those communities,
see what they're really like,
you know,
without,
without buying the bullcrap that I'm reading the propaganda in our popular press
and to say no,
these,
these people,
I don't hate everybody there.
I don't.
And there in lies the basis of hate is fear.
When you fear something,
you hate it.
You have to hate it because it,
it's a threat to you.
So this is why,
you know,
I mean,
tying it all back into the animal rights,
they're,
you know,
they hate us because they fear,
they fear you because you represent,
you're not,
you're not supposed to be talking positively about hunting.
You told this company line down here in California and just this is where it
should be in Hollywood.
You got,
you can't do this.
So,
so this the same thing for over there in these countries,
they want us to hate all these people because we're supposed to fear him.
And most people fear them because they don't.
It's unknown.
So I'd rather just go there and visit them and find out what's going on with
hunting as the,
as what I do,
which I also want to see what's going on with the wildlife,
how,
how are the wildlife these animals fairing with,
with all this going on,
I mean these people and what you find out is the hunters are taking care of the
wildlife there.
They're taking care of them in Russia,
they're taking care of them or all these crazy places where you'd expect it's
anarchy knows not.
They're still,
the wildlife has still benefiting from the conservation efforts of hunting and
that,
that's what I always hope to find out when I go to these places sometimes.
Sometimes,
you know,
it's not the way it is,
but that whole journey,
that's all part of hunting.
It's all part of hunting.
That's a voyage of discovery and that's why back to the people see a smiling or
you know,
with that animal dead animal,
you're,
you're smiling about the killer.
The animal that's sick,
wrong does not worth smiling about.
Where smiling about the process that was involved to get to that animal.
I mean,
we,
we had to think about where to go learn about the animal,
learn the skills to actually hunt it,
learn the skills to shoot whatever we're shooting with rifle even that isn't
easy.
We have to then learn to track it,
wait for it.
How the patients,
we have to know when to move the wind.
We have to,
we have to live this animal's life in,
in sort of a counterbalance until we cross paths and we kill it.
That's what the picture represents.
That whole process.
And when you add in a place like Pakistan,
you know,
I'll have,
I mean I've got a big smile if I'm,
whatever animal I've hunted.
But there that the,
that degree of difficulty is just so much higher because there's all these other
elements you shouldn't have to be,
you know,
looking over your shoulder and,
and wearing a shalwar Kameez and the Topi Cindy hat,
you know,
to go hunting.
But you have to,
you know,
this is becomes part of it.
So for me,
it's all exploration discovery.
And the hunters is the theme to it all.
That the thing that ties us into,
it's a network around this entire planet of hunters that are looking after the
wildlife and,
and who for the most part or are the good people,
all of this world and you're wearing the traditional garb of these people and a
lot of the places where you go,
it's not like you're wearing like Sitka digital cammo and you know,
we are you wearing like what they wear so that you fit in?
Yeah.
Depends.
It depends on where I am there absolutely.
There is not to blend in with the,
the environment is to blend in with the culture.
You know,
I did you walk around with Justin a cowboy hat like I would hear and cowboy
boots,
I look a little weird when you're,
you're right on the know on the Swat valley.
Well,
you know,
on the Caricom highway,
I mean,
you just would stand out too much.
So I'd rather look like a posh tune warrior,
then I would,
you know,
uh,
cowboy from the West.
So,
so,
and that,
you know,
again,
it's not fear,
it's just adapting.
It's just you,
you want to walk in there just like that.
Go ahead.
You know,
all the more power to you,
but you know,
be prepared because you're,
you're just a target at that point.
And,
and it's almost disrespectful in some ways.
When you go to these countries,
do you bring a translator?
Do you hire someone before you get there and to translate,
do you,
do you hire someone who's integrated into the culture?
Like how do you,
how do you set these things up?
Well,
like,
like I said,
there's a net network
of hunters around this world that are,
that are conserving wildlife.
They're looking after the wildlife of this world and,
and make no mistake,
every wildlife population on this planet is managed to some degree or other
nowadays that the world is just crushed with,
with humanity.
So every,
every single big game animal,
a small game animal,
they're all managed.
So there is hunters around the entire world and,
and all work that network to find who's there.
You know,
that,
you know,
they're the hunter.
They know they,
they,
they know the places to go.
They,
you know,
they're proud to be hunters are happy to help you out to take you to this place.
Now on the translation basis,
we do our best,
but it's a,
I mean I was,
I did a self guided hunt into the jungles of Cameroon in west Africa,
right on the Congo border.
And we literally took a bus from,
uh,
we landed into Walla airplane,
took a bus and we were the only white people on that bus and then that bus
station to Yoni and then hired a taxi cab to take us as far out into the Bush on
the Bush trails as the tax.
We would go another eight hours,
ended up in a little village filled with pygmies and there's another tribe that
will come to me,
but they,
they,
uh,
we hired them to be our,
our,
uh,
our guides into the forest.
Then we hiked into the forest for two weeks and hunted.
My translator was the only translator I've ever hired that could only speak one
language French.
So that was my,
that was my,
my attempt at that point to,
to hire a translator.
We,
it works sometimes,
sometimes it doesn't,
you know,
so it's uh,
but you know,
the language of hunting is,
is,
uh,
is co,
it's like a universal language.
We,
I can talk with anybody Swahili.
It doesn't matter.
We can,
we can converse because we know what we're talking about.
That sounds like such a crazy plan.
Hire a cab to drive you as far as he's willing to go on these roads into the
Congo,
then you get out and what are you camping?
Yeah,
we,
we actually had a little pup tents.
It was just me and my cameraman and,
and uh,
yeah,
we just hiked into the jungle and,
and wandering around the jungle for two weeks.
And it wasn't in the Congo by the way,
cause that would be illegal.
It was,
it was,
but it was very,
very close to the Congo that it's illegal to hunt in the Congo.
Uh,
it's not illegal to hunt,
but there is no,
in the Congo itself now,
Congo Brazzaville,
I've hunted there you can hunt.
There's actually a,
a mandate.
It's its proclamation with the government that you can,
you can hunt.
There's a way to do it,
so very complicated way,
but you can do it.
But in the,
the,
the Congo Democratic Republic of the,
they're hunting,
the animals are getting hammered in there because of the civil wars.
There is no oversight in there.
I mean there's animals.
The Okapi is in there,
they're being slaughtered and there's no,
there's no hunting without hunting,
there's no one overseeing it.
Now,
there will be some biologists,
uh,
you know,
they're probably the bravest of the brave actually when you're,
when you break it right down,
they go into those places and,
and do their best to protect it.
But it's,
it's a losing battle right now in that country.
Wow.
So you are with just you and a camera man and you bring just one rifle.
Yeah,
I had a muzzle loader actually.
Yeah.
It was a
not with a muzzle loader.
Is it extra challenge or something?
Yeah.
You know,
you know what I started,
it was a bow hunter and,
and I realized fairly quickly and that,
that beginning of my career that I wasn't patient enough to be a bow hunter.
I mean,
I trust my,
my skills and old gamble on my skills every single time.
And the problem with bowhunting,
you can't do that.
There's just rules.
You can't shoot an animal quarter towards.
You shouldn't shoot it.
You know,
if it's severely quartered away,
if it's,
you know,
if it's ready to jump string,
you can't,
you shouldn't shoot if it's a greater distance and 40 years now everybody's
skill level is different.
So a guy that Cameron Hanes,
I,
you know,
I'd say Cameron,
shoot,
if it's 80 yards,
he,
cause he's going to be able to hit it.
In those days,
the equipment,
I was using,
finger tabs,
there was none of the modern,
it was compound bows but barely compound.
And,
and I actually wounded a dear one day and I,
and I,
uh,
it was horrible.
I had to,
I couldn't get close enough for a second shot.
I had to watch it die.
And that,
that,
uh,
that I,
I just said,
look,
Jimmy face it,
you should never have taken that shot.
You did.
And now this animal suffering,
it's wrong.
And so I put my boat down and I picked up a muzzle or,
because that still gave me the challenge of archery hunting where I had to do
the same stocks,
get justice clothes.
But when I took that shot at,
you know,
55 yards,
which is how far that Deere was with a muzzle or you know,
I'm going to kill it and it's going to be humane and done,
done deal.
And so that's why I switched the muzzleloader rifle for me wasn't,
it just wasn't as challenging.
Now as I'm hunting and some of these places around the world nowadays,
I'm back to using a rifle occasionally because there's places you just can't get
within three,
400 yards of these animals in the mountains.
What about a second shot?
Like a followup shot?
Like,
if the,
if an animal is wounded and is trying to take off and you would normally be able
to just with a bolt action rifle and have another shot in the chamber ready you,
it takes what,
30 seconds?
Uh,
if,
if I was with a speed loader waiting,
anticipating having to reload quickly,
I can do it in about 30 to 40 seconds.
Uh,
but then you know,
and then acquire the target and shoot.
So you're about a minute.
The,
the uh,
you know,
the idea of using a muzzle loaders that you have to get close because you don't
have the range that you would with a high power rifle and that you have to make
the first shot.
Perfect.
I mean,
that's all you don't,
you don't really have an option.
So,
so you know,
the more opportunity or humans,
right,
the more opportunity we give ourselves to do it the easy way.
We'll do it the easy way.
Second Shadow,
cal reload and shoot again.
No.
So I actually almost never have a second load ready to go.
I just,
I make sure I don't take a shot unless it's perfect.
Now that,
you know,
we're still human so you can mess up,
but,
but that's not an alternative.
And,
and it gets a little hairy on dangerous stuff.
It's,
yeah,
I would imagine.
Yeah.
It's,
it's not that,
that I,
I don't,
I can't say that I enjoyed,
you know,
sneaking in on Cape Buffalo and
they're just,
it's just a scary situation.
I know.
The thing is,
it may not be me that gets hurt.
Maybe it's the,
the native tracker that's helping us out.
You know,
someone's going to get scratched or spit on or stumbled and it's going to be
because I was,
you know,
hunting with a muzzle or that's a bit of a stunt.
Uh,
I was just in Africa here,
uh,
just got back,
actually,
it probably don't even know what time it is here,
but,
uh,
one 20.
Okay.
It's probably midnight for me right now.
So it,
you know,
I was over there and I was using a rifle.
I didn't take my muscle,
I took my bowl and a and a high powered rifle and I got to say it was kind of
Nice,
you know,
to,
for once to go in on these Cape Buffalo and not have to worry.
I've got a rifle that I'm entirely capable of taking care of the situation.
In fact,
we got a,
I was going to bring you the footage,
but my computer died.
It was uh,
uh,
we were charged by a hippo.
We were hunting a hippo that had been terrorizing the village and they wanted us
to help.
It was wrecking their crops and it was one particular hippole.
So we were sneaking along a river.
I and you know,
sort of a creek,
um,
thick,
thick stuff working our way along.
We could hear the hip as they come home.
You hear my audio and how's it going again,
I'm not a good hippo color.
I'd never went in the national hip calling contest.
But,
uh,
as we went,
we were sneaking,
I s we saw this hippo that we're after one came from behind us,
literally hunting us and,
and came through the grass,
hit full speed when it was going 30 miles an hour and hit the opening or the
grass between me.
And it was 30 feet at that point.
Yeah.
And,
and coming at 30 miles an hour,
a hippo and 100% someone was going to get killed.
If I had my muzzle or my hands at that incident,
it would have been questionable if I could have stopped it.
But with the,
you know,
with a big rifle,
I did stop it.
Yeah.
It's all in camera.
It's incredible.
You see how quick it's like,
it's,
it's a 10th of a second from when you have to acquire the target shoot.
Ooh.
Yeah.
Scary stuff.
Wow.
So yeah.
You don't want to be with a Flint lock when you're doing that?
No.
Just the hang fire would be to get,
you know,
that took poof,
you're already dead.
You because cut half halfway that hip and they're actually people,
you know,
think hippo.
It's a big chunky beast.
What is ever do,
but they're behind crocs,
mosquitoes and puff adders hippos kill more people in Africa than any other
animal there.
There are a dangerous animal to hunt with their enormous too,
and they don't have any fear of crocodiles.
There's this crazy video,
these crocs that are hanging around this waterhole and the hippo walks through
him like it's a bunch of children.
Cool.
Excuse me.
Pardon me?
He's murderous.
Dinosaurs are floating around next to him.
He doesn't care at all.
It's the bottles through those crocs.
By the way,
I was in Mozambique to,
that was the last place I was.
Those Tanzania,
Mozambique,
Mozambique.
We were,
we were along the Zambezi river helping the villagers there.
They were getting hammered by these crocs that literally while we were there,
a woman got taken 800 yards down the beach from us,
killed dead eating and,
and we were there because another lady had been killed two days before we went
into the village.
There was a dozen people that were chewed up chomped on,
you know,
over the years that survived.
The majority.
Never ever survived.
The CROC.
Just comes up,
takes them underwater and gone.
Uh,
it was,
and they live with that every single day of their lives.
It's a,
you know,
those,
those animals,
Cox,
uh,
you know,
I actually don't feel much compassion for crocs.
I just think they're too primitive.
You know,
they haven't changed in 250 million years.
They were here,
they are dinosaurs.
They are dinosaurs.
And you see a 15 foot crock come out of the water.
It is a sight to behold.
Frightening.
And you've seen them in real life.
Yo,
I shot one here.
Just uh,
yeah,
two weeks ago and we autopsy that there was a shirt inside it.
They found her.
Yeah,
they found,
now I don't know if it actually eight somebody cause you don't know.
But they found one KROC had six flip flops in it and you know,
but we never did get the one that got the,
uh,
the young girl,
six flip flops inside of it.
So most likely it's been eating.
People don't know.
Don't know.
Right.
You don't know either that or it's a really dumb crock that has a thing for flip
flops floating down the Zambezi river.
It's more likely it's getting people I'd say so.
Yeah.
Yeah,
they are there.
200 people in a 10 mile stretch were killed in the last year.
Two years.
Wow.
So that's almost a person that day.
Yeah,
the Oh,
it absolutely is.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
It's a,
anyway,
that,
that's all part of uncharted.
That's what we were there.
It was helping us.
These villagers,
and this is an episode obviously you just shot.
So it's in the cat.
No,
it'll come out in 2015.
How many of them are you doing?
We do a 13 one hour episodes a year,
so we have to do 13 in the course of a year.
And you still doing your other hunting show is dot yeah.
Hunting adventures.
Yeah.
We do 26 half hour episodes of that,
but that I have helped cause Evy,
uh,
our daughters,
you know,
she's helping me coast at and,
and sometimes we'll do the opening side of things where we're guiding other
hunters.
So I don't necessarily have to be on camera for this.
Yeah.
And it's just kind of synchronicity that your daughter's in the news today and
she was on Fox and friends this morning defending this a bear kill because this,
um,
she put a Facebook post up and Steve Rinella has a very interesting take on all
this stuff.
There's the,
uh,
there's the picture of her with an enormous bear from North Carolina giant 510
pounds.
We can't play that,
but there's probably some better photos that there's a picture of her holding
onto the bear's head.
Um,
I think it's from Facebook.
They could fine,
but,
um,
Rinella has an interesting take on it that I think really holds a lot of weight.
And what he's saying is that a lot of what you're getting from these people that
are getting upset at,
uh,
these women posing with these bears is sexism.
That if it was a man posing with that band Facebook,
it wouldn't get nearly as much press or nearly as much interest.
He was a fat old,
bald man that had this date,
this dead bear.
They'd be like,
asshole hunter,
and that'd be the end of it.
But because of the fact that she's a young,
pretty woman,
they're attacking her.
I mean,
look at the size of that bear.
My God,
it's like a grizzly.
Uh,
it's a bigger,
most grizzlies,
it's enormous.
North Carolina has the biggest bears,
black bears in North America.
Really?
The other huge,
how big is that about?
Hers was 510 pounds.
Yeah.
Giant giant bears.
Wow.
Yeah.
You know,
when I,
I mean,
Steve is right.
Absolutely.
It is sexist.
But I think the reason that there,
there's such the Vitrail from these animal rights people is that they are scared
to death about this as being the image of hunting the new image.
You know,
it's easy to stereotype.
me,
I'm,
go ahead.
You know,
I am what I am.
Right.
You know,
and it's easy to stereotype.
that that big slovenly hunter that,
you know,
swells beer and shoots out the truck window,
it's very difficult.
What do you do with that?
Right.
Would he do with a young,
beautiful smile on her face?
They are scared to death.
They're scared to death of the,
this,
this impact because the women prior to this generation,
very,
very few of them hunted.
Now it's the fastest growing component of the hunting side of the world that
they,
uh,
I talked to the guys at bass pro shops,
Johnny Morris and he said 10 years ago,
3% of their customers were female.
Today it's 30%.
So this is the fastest rising part of our,
our industry.
The hunting industry is the female component,
the animal rights.
People look at this and go,
how do you battle that?
How do you battle that?
You,
she's a beautiful young lady,
articulate.
She,
you know,
she's not a a red neck lote,
which,
you know,
I mean you can cheap shot me for that,
but you can't cheap shot her for that.
She's got a degree from a university.
She and she hunts and she's,
she's beautiful and pure and her reasons for hunting
well did,
the other thing that was really disgusting was on Facebook people,
they were,
they were telling,
they were saying horrible things about her,
but they were also saying horrible things about killing her dog.
Are you an animal lover or would you just the hair evil person.
She did a fantastic job on that.
Fox and friends,
by the way,
because if you didn't know that she was a hunter,
you would think she's some news correspondent or something.
She comes off,
she's very articulate,
very well spoken.
She's not overly emotional.
She's too,
she doesn't distort the reality of the situation.
She's just talking about in a very clear,
concise way,
which is pretty remarkable for a young girl.
Yeah.
She,
uh,
she,
Evie is a very special young lady,
you know,
uh,
her mother and I,
Louisiana actually,
that's our be our 30th anniversary here in another few days.
Very,
very proud of a baby.
Um,
you know,
that's a tough thing to sit.
You know,
she's,
I'm,
I've,
I'm prepared to fight that battle,
you know?
I mean,
I,
you know,
I'm a warrior for this stuff.
Go ahead,
bring it on.
You want to argue,
debate,
what do you,
what basis religious,
cultural,
you know,
family.
How do you want to talk about this biologically?
I can find,
I can,
I'll argue with you.
Evie is a young lady who's just do it because she loves to hunt and she knows
it's good for conservation,
good for the animals in Long Island and she loves to hunt,
you know,
pure and simple.
And it's a tough thing to be thrown in front of a national television camera and
asked hard questions about it.
And so we're,
yeah,
we're very proud of her.
And I,
you know,
hard to say where this all ends up,
but,
but I know one thing that the animal rights people are,
and,
and uh,
you know,
the majority of the people or the 80% in the middle,
10% hunt,
10% hate it.
80% of the people are riding the fence swinging one way or another depending on
what they hear or learn.
But for the most part,
if you educate them there,
there is only one logical answer,
one logical way.
This whole thing can be played out.
Hunting is good period.
You know,
he may not want to do it yourself.
That's fair enough.
But slamming hunters.
In fact,
you know,
Evy made a mention of it on her,
uh,
on the Fox and friends.
If,
uh,
or maybe it was on the blaze,
I think on the Internet,
if every dollar that people donate to organizations that try and stop hunting or
actually aiding and abetting the poaching and the decimation of our wildlife
around the world.
Now that's a weird thing for people to,
to computer and their brand.
How does that work?
Well they,
if if in a place like lists lists,
let's pick a,
the Serengeti Park for instance,
Serengeti is,
and I,
you know,
go off continent cause this is an easy one to use as,
as a,
as an example,
the Serengeti Park is this huge area that wildlife essentially is protected by
dollars from tourism,
tourism being photo safaris,
photo safaris,
photo safaris essentially.
But it's only that area.
But the,
the wildlife of the Serengeti isn't just,
isn't just in the Serengeti.
It's,
it's,
uh,
crosses the borders.
It's outside of that.
There's,
you know,
less and less animals.
The further away you get because there's more and more people coming in.
This is in Tanzania.
So what they've done is they've created border hunting areas.
And this,
this is what the government in,
in full,
you know,
recognition of the value of hunting as a conservation tool.
They have the,
and now a buffer,
a huge buffer that's thous tens of thousands of miles where hunting dollars are
the only thing that financed the protection of those animals.
Now,
if the animal rights guys,
or if,
if the animal rights people convince Joe Blow public,
you know,
somebody sitting in their apartment in New York City that you'll donate your
money,
this will stop hunting.
You'll,
you'll stop those bad hunters from killing the animals,
what they're doing.
And then those guys,
they have the money.
They go in there and they,
you know,
they uh,
rally the forces.
They,
they,
uh,
convinced the government that all you've got to stop hunting if they get the
World Bank behind them are some very wealthy,
prominent people to support it.
Suddenly they stopped hunting.
Now what happens at that point?
They stop hunting.
Kenya,
here's an example.
Kenya.
They stopped hunting in [inaudible] 72,
the animals are,
are decimated outside of these parks.
There's nothing left in Tanzania.
There's still animals outside of the parks because of hunting.
You stop hunting.
So those dollars go into an anti hunting organization.
They go their lobby over those in,
in those foreign countries,
and you can buy just one.
Anything over there.
They buy support.
Not,
not saying that's how they do it every single time,
but it does happen.
They stop hunting,
no more hunting there.
So all those animals outside of the park are protected now by who?
Who's paying for the anti poaching patrols to go around the border?
Nobody,
there's no money.
There's no economics.
They add.
So what happens,
the poachers come in like a tidal wave,
wipe out all the animals and the next boundary they're going to cross it are the
parks.
So essentially the money that these people are donating to,
the anti hunting organizations are aiding of betting that the,
the criminals,
the poachers to decimate the wildlife populations.
It's a weird thing,
but it's,
it's counterintuitive,
it is a fact.
It is a reality.
Hunting dollars are the only thing that are protecting those animals in those
areas like the mass while areas it works.
It's a model that works and it can work all over the
world.
Isn't that just Africa though?
I mean,
how does that apply in America?
I mean the punch of the poaching issues not nearly as large in America.
No,
it's,
it's not,
it's not a poaching,
but its habitat loss.
You,
you have to look at it as,
as you know,
poaching is a guy with a snare or a set gun or a leg hold trop.
But while they,
or habitat loss is by far and away the greatest danger the wildlife faces here
in North America,
so you've got to have that wildlife land set aside for them.
Now it's a luxury in our world to be able to say,
here,
we're going to have this as a park,
and this,
you know,
no hunting in this area.
There's a corridors.
It's a luxury.
So right now,
maybe it's not quite quite as important as it would be over in Africa.
There it's a war.
I mean,
it is literally a war in wildlife over there.
Over here,
it's not as important,
but we still can never,
never let our guards down because there's always a push.
Humanity is going to push those,
those animals out of that habitat.
You're talking about it in Jersey.
Wah.
Why are the bears there?
Well,
because there's not enough space for the number of bears outside of the city.
So they're moving into the cities.
When it doesn't work,
they're going to kill the bears.
So we have to,
okay,
then let's make buffer zones.
Let's do it.
We can list,
let's get more area for these bears.
You know,
let's not put subdivision over there.
Let's let the animals live there.
But if we're not going to put a subdivision there,
that's going to cost somebody some money.
So,
okay,
how do we buy that land?
Well,
you can do it with taxpayer dollars and just print money or you can actually do
it in a revenue based,
uh,
concept or model where the animals get the money through the hunting and they
can buy back that land or on behalf of them,
we can buy back the land.
The habitat.
One of the big controversies when it comes to Africa as the high fence hunting
operations,
it's a very,
very contentious issue.
These areas where they fenced off these large tracks of land and the only reason
why they've done it is so that these wild animals can live inside and people
show up and they pay,
pay a lot of money and they go in and hunt does pros and cons.
The pros being,
of course,
the animals or the exists in much higher numbers than they ever have in the
past.
Animals that were on the verge of extinction and now flourishing,
they have massive populations and the reason being is because they're a valuable
resource now.
But people have an issue with that high fence thing.
The fact that they're all trapped in this area and then they can't get out,
even if it's 10,000,
a hundred thousand acres,
it's still kind of bugs people that you're hunting essentially in a fenced in
backyard or park.
That's the,
that's the idea behind it.
Yeah.
That's a far more complicated issue.
I heard you and Steve Vernella talking about it actually,
and it's,
you have to be their feet on the ground to get a real grasp of what the
situation is.
And,
and,
and even,
even on a philosophical basis,
it's,
it's far more complicated than,
than just animals are trapped inside a big area and the hunter is going to kill
him.
Um,
as a,
for instance,
and,
and I,
you know,
I,
I was actually asked to do a,
uh,
I used to write,
that's how I started in the outdoor industry.
I wrote magazine articles and I was asked to do the con side of,
of high fence hunting,
which I was no problem doing because I didn't believe in,
and I thought it was a bad thing.
And I,
and I did it,
but you know,
I,
and I received death threats from the,
the guys that do the game farms.
So they,
you know,
they,
they were very unhappy with the version I took of it.
Uh,
but,
but it was an assignment.
But what I did on the assignment afterwards,
I started looking,
well,
you know,
maybe there is something,
maybe there is another way to look at this.
And,
and I mean,
I'll,
I'll adjust this whole thing if you wanted,
if it will start right off the bat.
Okay.
You've got say a patch of 10,000 acres,
you know that,
that's a big area.
You know,
it's,
it's more than 10 square miles.
Um,
it,
it's a big area.
If the animal that you're hunting has a home range of,
say,
one square mile,
that means he never would have been outside that fence,
whether it was there or not.
And I'm not standing up for high fence hunting.
I'm just giving you a,
I'm objective.
Yeah.
I'm looking at it from the other side.
If,
if that animal has a home range in one square mile,
then you know,
is it really inside the fence if it never hits that boundary.
Now my argument on the other side was,
okay,
well if I want that animal,
I'm going to bulldoze that entire 10,000 acres.
I will get it.
Can't get away.
Okay,
got you.
On that one.
What if you're only allowed to hunt in one square mile of that 10,000 square
acres,
right?
Is that now is that hunting because the animal street to go outside of your
little one mile,
but you're only allowed to hunt in that one mile.
Right?
So now,
yet,
can't get out of the 10,000 acres,
but it can sure as heck get away from you as a hunter.
So there's another way it said another gray area.
What if there's one,
if there's,
you know the,
you know they say high fence,
but high fences,
an eight foot high fence usually with electric wire around it and page wire or
you know,
they call it Jocko wire along the bottom.
What if it's a low fence?
Is that okay?
You know,
does a hunter that hates high fat high fence hunting,
would he say it's okay to hunt in a low fence?
It's four feet high.
Most animals can jump over it.
But what about the ones that can't,
you know,
it's just as effective as a high fence.
Bonta Buck,
you know,
there's animal in in Africa that can't jump over a fence or a springbok.
They don't jump over fences.
They'll try and go through it.
But if there's a jackal fence along the bottom of that four foot fence,
they won't go through it.
So they're just as,
they're just as kept inside a certain range as those animals inside the high
fence.
So,
but with the guys that have this huge hate of the high fence,
they'd have no problem honey and low fence.
But the animal still just kept in there,
can't get out.
No animals like eland and Kudu,
they'll go over it.
Right.
The other,
the other flip side to that is those fences that they built in Africa,
we're not to keep the game animals in there to keep people out.
And to say that it was only for hunting isn't true either because a lot of them
make their living with photo safaris.
Now as the animal's multiply inside those high fences,
what do you have?
You have the same situations of bears in New Jersey.
You've got to go manage that hurt.
So now,
now after a couple of generations of this high fence ranching and in southern
Africa,
even the photo safari places,
they're adamant about against hunting,
they're realizing,
oh,
we're going to go in there and call these animals.
Something has to be done.
There's too many animals inside these fences.
So what they've actually started doing over there,
and again this is fairly new developments in Africa,
they're starting to build these conservancies where you had a 10,000 acre patch
here that was high fenced rate against it,
a 50,000 redgate's at another 10,000 another 20,000 and they were all high
fenced other shared fences.
What they're doing now is they're removing all the fences.
They have enough area and these conservancies,
you know,
500,000 acres with no fence around the outside.
So essentially the good of the high fences,
whether you agree with hunting inside the high fences are not the good.
The benefit is now years later the fences are all down and in those
conservancies there's no fences on the outside.
So you're hunting wildlife that would not have been there except for the high
fences.
So again,
I've,
you know,
I've taken the,
no,
not the pro side.
Cause do I,
do I enjoy hunting inside of high fence?
Will,
you know,
to me,
I get to hunt in the Himalayas,
you know,
I get down to the rocky mountains and we're spoiled over here.
You know,
we have that,
you know what I would I go into a,
you know,
a thousand acres and shoot a big deer?
No,
it would be nothing to me.
It would,
it would be like,
I wouldn't go shoot a cow or wouldn't want someplace.
It's not even a thousand.
I mean,
Ted Nugent has like a 200 acre ranch
and his show,
a good percentage of his show was him sitting in a tree in his backyard shooting
these animals that live in his yard have a pile of corn.
I can't,
I don't know how big Ted's ranches,
it's only a few hundred acres.
I,
but I do know one thing that Ted is as an oat sport at outspoken proponent of
hunting and,
and the right to bear arms.
I don't know anybody that reaches more people that was messages,
you know,
it's Ted,
it's all ted is pure Ted.
But if you read his books,
a lot of it is just common sense on steroids,
you know?
And that,
that's,
that's Ted.
So I,
you know,
I won't,
I mean,
I appreciate that he'll stand up there and fight our battles.
I don't think there's anything wrong with what he's doing.
Let me clarify the fact that he's hunting these animals in his,
his own piece of property.
I think it's a great way to acquire,
meet if that's what he wants to do.
And if he needs to manage his hurt.
And,
and I know he donates a lot of the food to a hundred hunters for the hungry.
I know that nothing goes to waste.
Nothing.
Absolutely nothing wrong with never way better than farming or then you know,
having some animal to corral that you just fattening up and you mentioned the
going to shoot him in the head.
I mean it's,
it's way better.
These are,
these animals are essentially living a wild life in a contained area and then he
shoots him.
I don't even have a problem with him leaving out food for them and then shooting
them off a bait piles.
I mean it's an effective way to make sure that you have a clear shot.
I think he's got really bad knees anyway.
I don't think he can like go hiking up into the hills and go looking for him or
anything.
I know I've seen him perform.
He's a,
if he's got bad knees,
he hides the pain.
Well,
he's a,
he's an amazing performer.
Well my friend Ben O'brian was telling me about how I went to see Ted Nugent
backstage.
He's got ice on his knee,
just got done with knee surgery.
He looks at,
he's in a wreck.
He goes on stage and just hammered.
It goes crazy.
It's jumping around like a 20 year old man.
Yeah,
he's,
he's a fucking pro and hard worker and a minute he's,
yeah,
he's,
he's on our side.
Yeah.
He's crazy as hell.
But a lot of what he says has merit.
You know,
a lot of what he says when it comes to hunting and conservation as metal.
But one of the times he's almost his own worst enemy with is all the Yahoo Gonzo
stuff that he,
it's,
he takes it so far and like threatening the president and all that shit when
they had a visit them with the secret service and go,
come on line.
He can't say stuff like that.
Like what are you doing?
Yeah,
he runs at a,
at a high speed.
He runs at a high speed and you know,
sometimes it trip.
Yeah.
So if you're going to run that speed.
Exactly right.
And that's,
you know,
you were,
we'll all sit there and countenance every word before.
Say It,
you know,
ted,
you know that he's,
he's just at a speed that my brain doesn't work that fast without care.
Who's made it is eventually,
like you say,
you're going to trip.
Well,
he also has some preprogrammed sentences that are ready to go.
He could just press play,
you know,
and just drop of a hat.
He can say spiritual back straps and all this,
you know,
he has all these things that he'll say the drop of a hat professionals,
but doing it for 40 years.
So,
exactly.
You know,
after 40 years if you,
if you don't have that and,
or he's also been defending hunting in the public eye long before it was
fashionable.
Yeah.
And he's debated like,
I've,
I've seen him debate.
Uh,
I don't know,
again,
I don't know the TV guys,
but one of those talky guys and,
and masterful,
masterful,
I mean,
he's just bang on and what he's saying now,
sometimes when he says it is a little harsh,
I mean it's,
it might be not,
not,
uh,
family friendly,
but it's,
you know,
it's Ted.
Ted.
Yeah.
Well did you see him debate Pierce Morgan?
I never saw that.
A little trial because he knew all the actual facts about gun deaths.
He's like,
do you understand that the,
the numbers that you're quoting also involve cops shooting bad guys?
Like you,
you're,
you're adding that in.
Do you know?
And Morgan didn't know for Pierce Morgan,
he's,
he doesn't know anything.
It's just he sees some numbers.
He's got them written down and he tries to throw them out there.
But new Jen has a deep understanding of what those numbers actually entail and
where they come from and what's really at the root of it all.
Sure.
Yeah.
And you can't argue with that.
And he's a,
he's a brilliant guy.
He's brilliant.
So he's definitely not dummy.
No,
no.
So He's just crazy.
Yeah.
He's fucking Ted Dude.
It was crazy.
Crazy.
Like a Fox Wango tango cat scratch fever.
I mean,
that's who he is.
Cat scratch fever.
I mean,
I grew up with this.
That's my,
a stranglehold,
one of my favorite workout music songs ever.
Um,
but you know,
the,
what I think is necessary today,
um,
when it comes to like a,
a modern face of what,
what hunting is,
is guys like you guys like you guys like Cam Haynes,
guys like Steve Rinella,
people who when you sit down and have a conversation with them and you realize
where they're coming from,
Pete,
people can,
are going to be able to relate to the message in a way that I don't think they,
I think it's too easy to marginalize someone like Ted,
unfortunately.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
I don't disagree with that,
but,
but by the same token,
he reaches more people than any of us do.
I mean,
you know,
we're reaching people today.
It's thanks to you and I mean,
this is why I'm here.
You're,
you're doing great work.
I mean,
you're,
you're putting yourself out there.
This is definitely not an anti hunting show.
You're not following the masses on this year.
You are reaching out and saying,
Hey,
this is something you want to think about.
So you know,
you're making a big difference.
Ted makes a difference in his own way.
Nope.
No question.
All,
I mean not putting them down.
Um,
I'm not putting myself out there though.
I mean,
I kind of am,
but I'm not because all the other thing I'm,
I'm so easy to marginalize already.
I'm a cage fighting commentator,
you know,
by the way,
saw you in the UFC 100 I was there.
My son and I,
they were
over the Brock Lesnar fighting.
Yeah,
we were,
we were guests of Brock Lesnar.
Actually,
I have his gloves after the fight with Frank Mir was blood on them.
He actually gave them to me after the fight.
Whoa.
Mouthpiece.
Oh yeah.
He took it out and put it in my pocket while I was interviewing them.
I still have it.
That was a,
that was amazing.
So I,
I mean,
I dunno about marginalized.
I think this is two worlds colliding.
In fact,
someone,
someone a Facebook me today,
I think,
uh,
said that,
that there are no,
they texted me and said that you are,
they listened to you when they're going out hunting,
right.
They're hunters and their UFC.
I don't know what they know about that,
but they know you and they know that you represent UFC and of course you did the
fear factor and whatnot in there.
These guys now they saying,
you know,
my world,
which they also listen to where it's,
it's colliding,
it's perfect for them.
It's,
it's,
it's building and reaching more people.
I definitely think that message is getting out there.
And I think today people are more concerned now than ever before about where
their food comes from and about getting to this sort of back to basics idea.
Um,
people are more concerned with eating grass fed beef.
People are more concerned with eating organic vegetables.
People are more concerned with taking in quality food and not eating as much
gluten and processed sugar.
There's,
there's much more concern now for eating what you would call a holistic diet
than has ever been before.
And then when people start thinking about where their food comes from,
that's what opens the door for hunting.
And then when a show like this comes on,
the difference between this and any other show is it,
first of all,
it's completely uncensored.
No one can tell us what to talk about or when not to talk about and we're going
to talk for as long as we want.
And so if you have a point you don't,
you don't get cut off by a commercial,
you don't get cut off because it's an uncomfortable subject.
You don't get cutoff because,
hey,
let's not talk about bears.
People don't like to hear you hunt bears.
Let's talk about only game animals.
Let's talk about some ugly.
Let's talk about pigs.
Wild pigs,
basic good know I'm be has problem with pigs.
I haven't.
My agent who I love to death,
she's a sweetheart,
she's an,
she loves animals,
but she's like,
you could hunt pigs because they're ugly checks.
He said,
that to me
is fair enough.
I mean,
the animal rights people who do they have as as their icons on their posters,
you know,
polar bear or a tiger or a lion.
The worst elements in the world to be stuck alone with.
Oh,
there you go.
There.
And also the ones that need our protection most right now.
Yeah.
Obviously Tigers,
right?
100% yeah.
There's as many tigers in Texas as there are in the wild.
That's a sad commentary series and those wild animal parks and people have like,
those are really crazy rich oil barons have these giant backyards like Mike
Tyson style,
like a thousand tigers running around.
I mean,
I think it's great that they're doing that because it does protect those animals
somewhere else outside of their native habitat.
But you know,
it's,
it's a sad commentary that there's so few tigers left in the,
in the real world out there and again,
they are being killed and they're being poached constantly.
Constantly.
Yeah.
So much so that,
um,
I was in,
I think it was Philadelphia regionally,
there's a big poster at the airport with a tiger's face that it said,
I am not a rug and I put it on my Instagram.
I was like,
is this isn't really that much of an issue that you have to like,
first of all,
anybody who's going to poach a tiger,
it doesn't give a shit.
If you put a poster of
it saying,
I'm not a rock,
there's still going to fucking shoot it.
I don't understand who that's for.
Well,
it's to raise money.
It takes awareness is to tug on the,
the sympathy strings of have that little old lady walking down there at the
airport going,
turning my tigers into rugs.
I mean,
that's terrible.
Look,
hunters aren't,
they haven't hunted taggers and since the colonial days,
I mean,
since since they left India,
I don't think there's been a tiger killed legally by a hunter.
So it's nothing to do with hunting and they're just,
they're raising money on our backs as hunters and still using that stereotype
that yeah,
we kill tigers to make them into rugs,
which we don't,
you'll poachers do poachers tournament to Aphrodisiacs I dunno.
Yeah.
Summary Rhinos to write Rhino Horn know harness is the latest one is what I was
over in Africa just now with the skeletons of,
of a alliance for some reason that that's got to,
you know,
they're on not kick now,
which is don't they know about Viagra?
I mean it's,
you tell him there's,
you can get a lot of Viagara you really don't need to,
you don't need to chop off any rhino horn.
You just go to cvs,
one tiny little pill and you're good.
And this is,
this is probably off color,
but it begs the question of why do they need so much viagara over there?
Like what's their problem?
Well,
I think it was before they knew about Viagra.
I think that's where all this rhino horn,
it became a part of the tradition.
The animal products from these virile,
powerful animals were thought of as aphrodisiacs or at least some male
enhancements and some sort of strange way,
you know,
the way they do it,
I think it's a status symbol too for them.
If you have your little tiny sliver of Rhino Horn that you dip into your soup,
I mean it literally,
that's what they do.
They'll keep it for years real and just dip it in there.
And that's,
that gives you this power.
I mean it's,
it's ridiculous.
It's ridiculous.
But,
but you know,
it's,
it's ridiculous.
But it's happening.
So the result is you've got 1.3 billion Chinese.
I'm not saying it's all China,
could be Korea as well.
Who knows where it's going over there.
There's just not enough rhinos to sustain that kind of a pressure and the prices
are going through the roof on the horns and,
and that's,
you got all the social problems in Africa,
so someone's going to go over and try and kill that Ryan.
Or even if they're going to be put in jail or shot,
you know,
by anti poaching teams,
they're going to do it because they get 500 bucks.
Which hole?
This is where it brings up a really interesting contradictory issue that rhino
that was put up for auction by The Dallas Safari Club,
right?
Huge issue because someone spent hundreds of thousands of dollars on this rhino
hunt to be able to go and hunt this rhino and everybody was so angry.
What they didn't understand was that that rhino was an old male who was not
breeding,
who was killing young rhinos.
He was killing young breeding rhinos and the only way to prevent that was to
kill him.
And the money that was raised by
auctioning off a hunt for this rhino helps in the conservation of the rhinos.
That's so difficult to,
it won't unless it's explained to you,
unless you're deeply immersed in the world of conservation and of hunting as a
form of conservation,
it seems completely contradict.
Yeah.
It was counterintuitive.
Yes.
How do you kill the animal to save the species?
Well,
it doesn't make sense.
And by the way,
that was Corey Knowlton who,
if you watch the uncharted is,
is my sort of teammate on several of the shows.
Um,
and I think the price was 250,000 or 350,000 for that.
They felt Dell Safari club felt that they would get over $1 million.
They had people that would have,
would have essentially donated very wealthy people that would have paid this.
Jamie just put up an article,
feds could force Dallas Hunting Club to scrap the rhino hunt auction to
$350,000.
Wow.
I haven't seen that test today.
Whoa.
Last night.
Oh Wow.
How Apropos.
Yeah.
The,
you know,
the US fish and wildlife has,
they're pretty powerful organization.
They can actually say,
well,
we're not going to let you import it.
Right.
But they can,
they can't stop an,
I can't say that they can't even stop that auction from,
you know,
it's already happened,
but they can't,
they can't stop it from hunting and because it's in another country,
but where they can stop,
it's him bringing the animal over after he settled.
For sure they can stop.
But they also might be able to after the fact,
say that was not illegal auction.
I don't know.
I've never heard of this.
This is the first I've seen of that title.
But they do have,
they're,
they're pretty powerful and they,
you know,
they do some good things and they do,
they do some things that don't make sense from the hunting side.
They do well,
they do some things based on political pressure and lots of that political
pressure is not based on wildlife management biologists recommendations.
Yeah.
The,
I think they stopped the importation of polar bears again recently after the 72
marine mammals act.
You know,
then they opened it again.
Cause there's so many polar bears up in northern Canada and Canada has
biologists,
they're smart guys,
they're doctors.
They know what they're doing.
The,
the communities up in the North or killing those bears anyway.
So why not have hunters come in and pay $20,000 so that a young one,
a young female breeding age doesn't get killed but just know board beyond
breeding age.
So us fish and wildlife for whatever reason,
you know,
and their wisdom and I,
I don't know them.
I don't,
I don't know what pressures they're under to make these decisions,
but they banned the importation again.
So now you know,
everyone else in the world is still hunting the polar bears in Canada,
just not American.
Well,
you can hunt polar bears in Canada,
which you can't bring back.
The body can import any point of,
they even know that it was still legal to Honamin Canada.
I just didn't know till I was up there.
Yeah,
absolutely.
A walrus.
Same thing.
Atlantic wall where you can hunt up there,
but you can't as an American bring them into the states.
Not even a whisker.
Isn't that the same with African elephants?
Like there's some African elephants that you're allowed to hunt,
but you can't bring the tusks back there.
They've just shut
down the importation from Zimbabwe and Tanzania recently with both countries
were until this year allowed,
you know,
can hunt them and bring them back into,
into the states.
They still allow the importation from Namibia and South Africa as far as I know.
Um,
but you know,
Cameroon,
they don't allow it.
Now this is us fish and wildlife.
It's a,
it's a national centric decision.
It's not a world decision.
There's sites that convention for the international trade in endangered animals
or species.
They control all of that export import around the world.
And the U S is a signatory to the site.
He's convention.
So they should listen to what [inaudible] does,
but they don't,
you know,
they,
they above and beyond that say no side,
he says it's okay,
but we say it's not.
And again,
I,
I'm not saying that they're right or wrong on that.
I'm just saying that they are very powerful and sometimes the decisions they
make as a hunter,
and again,
looking for my little mountain top at this whole objective picture and you know,
having hunted in Botswana,
you know,
for elephant Cameroon and,
and,
uh,
Tanzania,
all of these places,
you know,
it's,
it's was to the detriment of wildlife,
nay to the elephant as near as I can tell.
So I,
it doesn't make sense how they,
what was their justification?
I know they shut down the importation of polar bears from Canada because they
said the potential of,
of,
uh,
what was it,
global warming,
the impact of global warming over the next 50 years,
the potential is there.
So we're going to shut down.
Importation is just like,
this is reactive,
uh,
management.
It makes no sense.
Well,
if you pay attention to the stories on global warming,
most people believe that the polar bears are endangered.
Right now.
Most people believe that their habitat is being lost at an alarming rate.
That the ice caps are melting.
The,
the ice islands that they swim up to are going away.
If you talk to the average person that is aware of all the new stories on global
warming and you asked him,
do you think the polar bears endangered?
Oh yes.
Polar bears and danger.
Those drinking the Koolaid,
they,
you know,
they're not telling you is that there's the polar bear population is directly
proportional to the population of ring seals,
bearded seals and harp seals up there that these animals,
if there's a heavy freeze,
like say for instance we're going to hit another mini ice age,
which I'm old enough to remember back in the 60s when all these same scientists
were predicting ice age coming ice age,
it's going to be a mile.
I worried about that as a kid.
Right.
I'm going to,
you know,
I'm going to get my Toboggan and and you,
sled all my,
my toys down to Mexico cause I'm going to be a mile in rice here.
Right.
So the same guys,
now it's global warming,
global.
Well sort of because they have a lot more information nowadays.
You know,
they have more,
they have more to back it up.
But what they're not,
whether they're abusing is the,
the reality up there,
which is you need new ice fur seals to grow.
If they have old isis too deep,
the seals,
they die and they die.
The polar bears die.
So a mini ice age kills polar bears,
global warming.
This,
I still freezes every winter it freezes and the CEO's that come up through it
and the,
the bears can fight or fight through the ice,
find their seals and survive.
So there's more seals up now than there ever has been,
which translates to more polar bears than there ever has been.
And this is backed up by numerous studies up in Canada by Canadian scientists
and the,
and by anecdotal evidence,
just go talk to the new one up there.
You know,
back 40 50 60 years ago,
they had to work really hard to find a polar bear now and also remember that
there was commercial harvesting of these polar bears up until 1970 you know,
10,000 a year.
They were killing up in the northern,
in,
in the north.
Whether you're in between Russia and Canada,
just for the,
for just for the,
for now.
That's all gone.
So what do you think those bears did?
They had babies,
the ones that survived.
And those babies have babies.
There's bears everywhere up there now.
So again,
the in you know better than anybody.
They lived there when you can't walk out of your house and Nazi polar bear
tracks,
there's a lot more polar bear than there were.
So,
so again,
to say that global warming is potentially going to cause the demise a polar
bear.
So we're going to stop hunting,
devalued the polar bear for the new it up there.
The Americans were the main market for those polar bears for the hunters.
So what do they do now?
They still kill him,
but now they don't care.
The first one they see baby mother doesn't matter,
you know,
cause it's meat.
It's just plain and simple meat.
And is that a great way to manage the polar bear populations up there?
So he,
you know,
coming back to the u s fish and Wildlife Service,
I'm not saying that there,
I don't understand the logic behind their decision.
Now,
I would love for one of them to explain to me what the logic is,
but I don't see it on the ground,
feet on the ground in the Arctic.
And I was there this,
this spring for a month.
You know,
it's the same story.
More bears than ever.
It's so interesting how counterintuitive that is based on like what most people
believe.
Most people believe that this area is diminishing in habitat and that the polar
bear is going to be forced into extinction.
Sure.
Well,
meanwhile,
there's more than as it is,
it is really easy to take a picture of a mother polar bear with two cubs on a
tiny little ice cube out on the water and say,
you know,
my world is melting around me
dying.
And what would you do for a Klondike Bar?
I have a coke and a smile.
There you go.
I mean,
they're the most vicious predators we know.
And they're,
you know,
they're used to sell ice cream and soda.
They're there.
They're marine mammals.
That's,
they swim.
That's what they do.
You know
these animals are doing,
no,
no.
There,
there,
there's,
their habitat is lost.
They're drowning.
Oh,
don't,
you know,
that's ridiculous.
But it's also,
it's also a way for scientists who,
who,
and I use the term scientists lately,
the way for them to raise funds because you got to remember they have to pay for
their mortgages to,
so jump on the bandwagon,
let's get,
I'm going to study these polar bears now because look,
this is danger.
The threat.
And if you get enough people believing it,
then you know there's money available.
Right?
Okay,
let's give $25 million to studies now.
Now,
yeah.
I mean,
I'm sound like a conspiracy theorist,
but it's,
you know,
it's,
the reality is people are trying to make a living.
They're just trying to make a living and just trying to sell storage wars that
just trying to get you to look in Al Capone's vault.
That's right.
And they're trying to get you to send money and to their organization that's
raising whatever billions of dollars a year,
hundreds of millions to protect wildlife.
Have you eaten polar bear?
Oh,
absolutely.
What is polar bear?
It tastes like,
you know,
when I've eaten it,
it's up in the Arctic with the annual.
And so they,
they boil everything.
It's a boiled and,
and uh,
it's funny you put salt lick the brisket,
you normally where we need the backstraps,
you know,
that'd be the first choice or tenderloins the Inuit nod.
It's the brisket because when you boil it,
that's where you've got this great textures,
you know,
that they're crunchy.
Uh,
I mean,
I don't even know what you'd call a cartilage and connective tissue.
There's not just meat and fat.
So that's,
you know,
it was,
it was a delicacy.
I would rate it right up there with the best of the meat I've ever had now
Healy.
Oh,
absolutely.
But boiled with salt and being very hungry out on the ice.
You know,
you spent 20 days out in the ice with you,
it on a dog sled.
You're,
you're hungry.
He,
you know they kill a barrier unit near,
it's like the best finest Coby beef and downtown New York City.
Is it relative to where you're at in the struggle that your enemy,
if you had it,
if I took it to a restaurant down the street,
hard to say cause cause you there is no restaurant serves it.
So it's hard to hard to take it out of that context and say is it the best meat
now here,
I don't know.
I mean while cheap,
same thing.
You're on a mountain and you've been backpacking for 10 days carrying 50 to 70
pounds on your back and you finally get your realm and rundown to blow Alpine
and find some little sticks and make a fire and roast the ribs on it.
I defy anybody to tell me there's a better piece of meat in this world that
tastes better than that while cheap on a mountain after a sheep hunt.
But would it be that good if I was downtown New York City or here in La I,
you know,
I don't know because you,
you just can't do it.
It doesn't exist.
One of the best meals I've ever had in my life.
We shot a mule deer that,
that deer right there in Montana.
And uh,
we,
we ate the liver and the heart that night and it was insane.
It was so delicious.
Yeah.
That's the camp fire and just cooked it over oil with little salt and pepper and
then just moaning with delight like an orgy.
Anyone that doesn't hunt that isn't out there can never know what we're,
what you're describing.
I know it,
I know it.
I've had the same thing and I've had,
you know,
Moose liver and name it,
you name it,
you know,
antelope,
you all around the world.
We've had the same thing.
It's the best of the best.
It's the perfect,
I think it's because that's who we are.
That's who we are.
We're not the,
the fancy restaurant,
you know,
thousand dollar bottles of wine and whole,
whole,
whole cuisine is not what we are.
We're just,
we're just that we eat wild game cooked on a fire.
That's the choose we can ever be.
That's the truest,
most natural flavor and,
and eating that we could ever do.
But one of the number one post and when I Instagram pictures that like the,
the ones that get the most likes or all meat cooking wild game is crazy.
Yeah.
Wild pig or wild,
you know,
Santa or the Moose recently.
It's,
it's weird how people at resonates with people.
Yeah.
And again,
I think it w we are making inroads.
Like they're,
you know,
the hipsters nowadays are in the big cities are looking at this and saying,
hey,
yeah,
it's organic meat.
It truly is better than anything that's raised.
So I mean,
why not?
It's,
it's organic.
And if they look at it objectively and it's managed herds and it's,
you know,
there,
there's wildlife populations that can sustain a harvest of a certain number of
animals that's regulated.
Okay,
well why not?
Now?
Suddenly it makes all kinds of sense to not eat that instead of a [inaudible].
But it's not that simple to go get that,
you know,
you've done it,
you've made the effort,
you've learned the skills,
you know,
you shoot a ball,
you should arrive.
Do you rifle?
I don't even know.
But all those are skills that you've acquired.
You can't just walk out there and go shoot something.
Well,
I'm very lucky in the first of all,
lucky that I got to meet Steve are now on,
I have my podcasts and I got to take my introductory course in the hunting was
with a master hunter.
I mean took me out the right way in the wild and the Missouri breaks and place
where there's no people.
The deer that I shot most likely never even seen a person.
I mean,
you're in a very inhospitable environment for most people.
It's very difficult to do and very difficult to find the time to go to the range
to learn.
I mean learn how to bow hunt with Cameron Hanes.
I mean she's a very fortunate in that sense.
I mean,
he taught me so much about archery and equipment and how to,
you know,
adjust your equipment and dial it all in and had a practice and what to do and
you know how to stand and hold your breath and you know the proper way to
release all that stuff takes.
It takes a lot of it.
You have to invest a lot of time and energy that people,
a lot of people don't have,
you know,
they have this,
his cubicle existence,
whether they like it or not,
they're tied into their student loans and tied into their bills.
So when I talk about like those existences,
like I've been trapped too,
man,
I've had plenty of jobs.
It's sucked and I was stuck there forever.
But you what I,
what I'm saying is,
is not,
I'm not judging people for not being able to do it or not doing it themselves.
What I'm trying to do is just let them know the benefits,
if it's possible to figure out a way to get to that part,
to get to that point in your life.
The benefits of being able to do it.
The benefits,
being able to hunt your meat and actually kill that animal and cook that liver
over the fire.
You wouldn't believe how good it tastes you.
You literally wouldn't believe.
And it's a completely different thing.
I've had many delicious,
where I went to the store,
I bought a nice steak and I bought some vegetables and I came home and I cooked
it up and you know,
just no connection whatsoever to how that Kale was grown or how those mushrooms
are picked or how that cow die.
But it's still fantastic,
delicious meal.
But there's another level that comes from like this Mousse.
I cook some Moose last night,
does this,
this is a totally different level.
I know exactly where that animal came from.
I cut the backstraps off its body,
I put it in the plastic bag,
we froze it,
I took it home,
I defrosted it.
I,
you know,
I put the garlic salt on it and I started the fire,
the whole deal.
And when that,
this is a complete different thing when you're eating that and that's,
that's the next level of connection.
Yeah.
I think,
no question.
And that I,
I mean,
I think we're sitting in the popular person on television with,
with the,
uh,
you know,
guys like Anthony Bourdain and I mean,
I don't know the other cook guys,
but one of them,
I think it might've been him,
killed an Eland in Africa.
And that's hunting.
Yeah.
You don't know what,
what they're missing.
They're doing it very surgically.
They're not,
they're missing the spirituality of the hunting side,
the skillset.
You know,
I,
I'm not sure which one was how it happened.
I think it was shot right from the truck.
You know,
they missed the hunt part.
So their people are maybe coming in the backdoor on the,
on this whole hunting the issue.
Like,
okay,
we get the meat part,
right.
It's just the honeypot we don't get yet.
So,
so,
you know,
but if we reach them through the meat side and they recognize this as the best
meat that you can pause,
the best sustenance,
you can have the most natural,
then that's fine.
I'll take that any day.
Now here,
let me,
let me take you into the outdoors and show you the part that you don't get yet,
which is the actual killing of this animal animal and what that means to you as
a person that's going to then supply your family with this meat and eat it
yourself.
You know,
that,
you know,
besides the fact what the meat tastes like.
It's also that,
that uh,
it's a spiritual connection with,
with life.
I mean life.
Uh,
where do you think that that state came from and your,
you know,
life,
it was a life,
you know,
life begets death.
I guess life begets death.
This is,
this is the part that we've almost got the people coming in from.
Like I say,
the backside,
the meat side almost got them to where they understand now are there ready to
understand that?
Okay,
well now they're,
here's the death part.
This is the hunting part.
Yeah.
They accept the wild game and no question.
All our friends like wild game meat,
it w w we give it,
it's,
it's gone the instant we offer it to anybody.
But you know,
the hunting part,
they're still on the fence about so,
but,
but slowly,
slowly.
And if it has to come through the meat side with the cooking shows,
great.
And it will also push on the other side,
the exploration,
the,
the uh,
discovery,
the,
the skills that it takes and the joy to be out in the wild lands.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
I don't spend my day worrying about how to make enough money to drive a Rolls
Royce like my,
my neighbors.
You're a second TV or,
or,
you know,
whatever channel that people chase in this world today.
I don't do that.
I use my time and my money to be out there.
You say that people don't have enough time.
You do have enough time.
You just have to change your priorities.
You know,
instead of sending your kids off to the nannies,
want her to take them out there,
take them on into the,
the wildlands,
wherever that may be.
A maybe a 40 acre park,
but at least shout there,
show him a bug.
Show him an insect,
show him a butterfly.
Show him a bird.
And maybe you'll be lucky and see a squirrel or a rabbit and if you're really
lucky,
a deer,
you know,
that's,
it's just priorities.
There's time.
If people prioritize properly,
well to me properly,
maybe not to them yet because maybe they want the Rolls Royce,
you know,
it doesn't interest me.
I think there's also an issue that's coming up now where the,
the moral high ground that people take five by endorsing vegetarianism or
veganism,
we're starting to understand that that plants might be sent in,
that plants actually can communicate with each other,
that plants can transmit information,
that plants can feel pain,
that plants recognize when they're being consumed and that plants have
protective measures in order to discourage predation because in that protective
measures that become enacted upon them being torn apart or being eaten,
where we're starting to find out all sorts of strange things about plants that
plants might not be this.
We would like to look at plan as being like,
oh,
it's like fucking eating styrofoam,
which is grows.
You pull it out of the ground and it's,
it's fine.
What's a life form?
It's a life form.
It just because he can't scream when you eat it.
It doesn't mean it's not a life form like any other life form,
you know?
And it doesn't mean it's not screaming in a language.
We don't understand it.
You see the Kudu and Africa feeding into the windows that to protect them from
predators?
No,
it's,
it's because the plants that they feed on that they prefer Cat San pheromones or
whatever that,
whatever that signal is where they talk to each other and I mean it sounds like
doctor Doolittle here,
Mister Mister plant little,
but they are,
the plants actually send a signal to the plants ahead if it's downwind and they
all send out a,
a chemical and the leaves that make them inedible for the animals so that that's
there.
They're talking to each other and there's no doubt.
Now.
Now would that stop me from eating the leaves of that plant or lettuce or a
carrot?
No,
not a bit.
But you know,
I mean I guess if people want to sit there and say,
I don't kill things.
I would say more like you drive a car.
How many bugs do you think you killed in that car?
How many birds have you hit?
You know,
of course you're killing animals.
No,
no one can,
no one can wash their hands of that.
Well there was a experiment
that was recently done,
um,
where the student showed that plants won't grow near a Wifi router.
They show the difference in plant growth like we were near a Wifi,
grout router and a without,
and they're starting to realize that there's something that these,
these plants are,
they're interacting with their environment in ways that were not totally aware
of the same way sort how bees are affected by cell phone signals.
This is a huge issue with,
with bee populations.
I think that bees on a regular basis are dealing with radio frequencies and cell
phone frequencies,
Wifi signals.
These actually affect their,
their ability to communicate with each other,
their ability to,
um,
to navigate.
And that there's all sorts of things that the wild life,
whether it's wild plants,
whether it's insects,
animals,
there's their senses that they have.
There's ways of their interacting with their environment that we're not totally
aware of.
So when we look at a plant,
it grows and we go,
oh,
we'll just eat this plant.
And it's so simple and convenient because it doesn't scream because we don't
recognize it's life in the same level as our life.
We don't put it in the same hierarchy.
It doesn't mean it's not life.
Life eats life.
That's the exact correct.
Uh,
and I say life begats death,
the guest's life,
it's a continuum.
It's a perfect balance.
Has been going on forever and this planet,
and it's not going to change just because someone calls himself a vegetarian.
I mean it's,
it's animals die,
plants die so that we can live.
Now when you traveling to all these different worlds,
I mean,
there really are almost like different worlds.
It's different parts of this planet and your,
you're interacting with all these indigenous people.
What are they,
what's their attitude when it comes to vegetarianism?
And it was,
is that,
does that even exist in some of these places?
No,
I mean,
proteins at a premium all around the world.
It's a first world issue.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's our,
it's a luxury that we can call ourselves a vegetarian.
Now that doesn't mean that some places they're not vegetarian because they have
to be,
you know,
but if they get an opportunity to eat a fish,
they're going to eat it.
You know,
I,
it doesn't matter where you are,
whether it's,
you know,
you'll see the,
the pygmies and the creeks catching the little freshwater shrimp.
If they didn't catch an animal that day,
they're eating the shrimp,
you know,
their protein as is is a premium all around the world.
No,
there's no one
who is a third world that's not really a great term.
But
yeah,
I don't like those terms.
First World Thurber I,
you know,
I used that term about Mexico and I did it at a show once talking about San
Diego,
how weird it is.
A San Diego is just a 20 minute drive to Tijuana and this guy came up to me
after the show and he was from Tijuana.
He came to the show and he's like,
yeah,
I'm from a third world country.
Like you could tell like bothered him that I said that.
Well,
at this designation of first,
second,
Third World,
I was just in Mexico City.
Some of the nicest people I've ever met in my life.
They're so friendly and make Mexico City.
It's,
it's overly crowded.
It's unbelievably polluted.
But the people are fantastic.
Yeah.
And I think first,
second,
Third World,
all these distinctions at this,
it's kind of,
yeah.
Weird.
No,
it's just,
uh,
you know,
again,
it's,
it's ego centric.
Yes.
Like the world revolves around us.
It's earth.
Exactly.
And they're there.
It's just,
it's different situation over there.
But they don't have protein,
you know,
they're getting it from their bean plants or whatever.
They happen to be growing if they're agrarian.
But,
but you know,
that that whole vegetarian thing,
I've never met anybody in any place that says,
you know,
I'm a vegetarian.
They're proud of it.
They're vegetarian because the have to be,
there's no other food around and given a choice,
they will absolutely eat that.
You know,
clam,
fish,
crab,
whatever.
If they're,
if they're along the ocean or rivers.
A lot of people in India,
aren't they?
Vegetarian by choice?
Isn't that,
uh,
you know,
Hinduism,
I dunno,
you know,
that,
uh,
once you,
once you start injecting the religious side of it,
that's a different deal.
Chelios right?
Um,
you,
you doing 13 of these a year where you're traveling to all these ridiculously
remote places like that one where you went to Russia and he took that crazy four
wheel drive truck near the side of this cliff mean that I was clenching my fist
and tightening my legs watching that.
I was like,
Jesus,
what are they doing?
You took like the most precarious path to go.
Was it a ram you went to go shoot around?
Yeah,
yeah.
The
TN Shannon,
our galley and the TN Shannon mountains that was in Kurgastan,
right.
Uh,
an ex Soviet protectorate.
So it's a,
it's the only way to get there.
How long did it take to get to that spot?
You know,
that that time we were pretty lucky.
I think we did it.
And,
uh,
from where we left pavement,
I'm gonna say 14,
16 hours,
maybe it was 18 hours.
So,
you know,
somewhere in that range,
it's not bad sometimes.
And these places like to Gica Stan,
you know,
going along the Joaquim corridor there,
you can,
it can take 36 hours in one of those little Russian jeeps was a brutal,
brutal.
I swear,
they just run their exhaust pipe into the inside of the truck for their heater.
Really?
Yes.
I swear like it.
It's just,
it's disgusting.
You,
you're,
I have a headache pounding and you're up at 14,000 feet,
so you have a headache anyway.
But,
uh,
and you breathing exhaust fumes,
smelling exhaust fumes the whole way.
36 hours of sitting in a,
in a,
you know,
they're not made for comfort.
The,
the Soviet era,
anything was,
had nothing to do with comfort.
So,
yeah.
But so the Kurgastan wanted in that big Russian unilog deal was a,
you know,
relatively speaking,
it was fairly,
fairly quick.
Still still,
you know,
and,
and I,
I've just become a bit of a fatalist on that.
If I'm,
if it's my time and this thing's going to go over the edge,
it's my time,
you know,
and you,
you're not going to stop.
You can,
you know,
stress out the entire time and get shots of adrenaline every time that chuck
liens and lurches,
it's just not worth it.
You know,
I,
I just go on his own and,
wow.
What a beautiful view.
Straight,
straight,
willing to take you to these places.
They live there.
That's where they live there.
They're hunters.
That's,
that's where they have to meet you where they don't live and then take you to
where they live.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's the,
that's why you have those wonderful road systems the Soviets built.
Yeah.
Wonderful.
No,
I swear like you built them along the way.
Yeah.
They're there.
Uh,
there's the there,
but they're nowhere near as scary as down in South America and Peru.
Go in the Andes and,
and go into some of those communities where you're doing 20 switch batch
switchbacks up a mountain.
Frightening.
What does it switch back?
What does that well,
they,
the,
you can't,
they come one way up,
45 degree angle,
then cut 45 degree angle cut 45 cut 40.
Oh,
I see.
And you can climb almost any mountain if you build a road,
you know,
wide enough for a,
for attract,
uh,
wheels to go on.
And scariest thing I've ever,
ever scariest place I've ever driven.
You know,
Kurgastan was bad,
but,
but uh,
the Andes in South America and Peru were by far worse.
We were hunting a little white tail that lives only the Andys Andy and whitetail
deer.
He lives up in the high Andes at 14,
15,000 feet.
The only one animal is higher as the [inaudible],
which is another deer species.
That's,
that's higher.
Wow.
Fascinating place.
Have you hunted everything that's on this planet?
No,
but I'm sure.
Do you have a list?
Yeah,
well,
I had a bucket list.
Yeah.
I mean,
I like a literal bucket list for them to,
yeah.
I mean,
the thing is that because no one's going to discover a new big game animal in
this planet anymore.
I mean they were all at that Fang cheap or they're fang dear that they just
found in Afghanistan for 60 years.
I heard about that.
But that just start salivating if they,
if they were allow hunting.
The thing is,
the thing is probably they could raise $1 million if they auction off a tag to
one hunter who knows a Russian oligarch guy,
he had paid the money.
Oh he probably doesn't.
He'd go hundred anyway.
But,
but if they raised $1 million for conservation of that animal,
they'd lose one.
But they'd saved the whole species,
you know,
in the,
and they protect it,
give the animals money.
They buy back some space for themselves.
So in fact,
you know,
I,
I would actually like to see one of them hunted,
maybe not 20 of them hunted when there's so few of them.
They didn't even know it existed until recently.
I thought the numbers can't be healthy enough to kill one.
Can they?
Probably not.
Not at this point,
but look at it this way.
What if there's one like the rhino,
the Black Rhino.
What if there's one that's overbreeding age pass breeding age,
right?
So he's not contributing to the preservation of that species anymore or the or
the perpetuation of that species.
He's just living.
So if you lost that one,
raised $1 million for a study of those animals and the protection of those
animals,
can you justify it?
You know?
And again,
it's,
it's a life,
you know,
to protect more lives or,
or don't take the million dollars that one dies because he's gonna die.
He's gonna die for whatever.
Cause you know,
whether he gets pneumonia or whatever,
those Fang dear whatever they die from.
So it,
it just dies and there was no million dollars,
you know,
so now they're still struggling to get financing to,
to protect these animals.
They could have done it with one auction,
with one tag,
wouldn't we?
The argument against,
obviously I'm playing devil's advocate here,
it was like,
wouldn't it be better if people were just,
we just wanted to keep these animals alive and it for a charitable reason.
I mean,
people would say like,
why do we have to hunt these things?
Why can't you just just keep these things alive because you care.
Because you want to see them flourish.
That's a who was somewhere over the rainbow.
Disneyland.
I mean those,
those places exist,
but not in the real world.
Not right now.
No.
Nobody has a,
nobody's going to give $1 million to protect the Fang deer in Afghanistan.
It's not going to happen,
you know,
and they can go try and raise money,
but you know what,
if you're going to raise money,
would you use a picture of a fang deer from Afghanistan or,
or you know,
a pretty,
uh,
an hour?
Yeah,
an eagle or you know,
something else.
Anything else?
A Fang deer that people just look and go,
yeah,
this is kind of like a pig,
you know?
It's a weird,
it's got thanks.
What do you,
how do you feel about hunting animals that you don't eat?
It depends what you mean by that.
Because there's,
there's almost no animals that are hunted that aren't utilized as food.
So,
you know what I mean?
Is Hyenas would be the,
they call him cousin over there.
So they high needs,
they don't eat.
Um,
you know,
that's a tougher one.
It is a tougher question,
right?
And it's not one that,
uh,
not one that I have a ready answer for because you're a wolf for instance.
I understand that wolves kill my Caribou in the Yukon and my opening territory
up there,
they kill the heck out of Caribou.
They kill the heck out of,
uh,
Moose.
Whatever they can kill,
they're going to kill the sheep.
You're,
that were struggling to raise the populations on.
So,
you know,
a wolf to say don't kill a wolf.
It makes no sense.
They have huge letters.
They,
they,
you know,
they work on a boom and bust with a natural cycle,
the kill everything.
So then they all die off and then everything starts again.
And that's all fine and dandy.
If you don't want x amount of ungulates around,
you know,
they're,
they're going through it in Yellowstone right now.
So,
you know,
should you kill it,
you don't eat it,
you know,
who doesn't mean you can't eat it?
I mean,
that's nothing wrong with wolf made.
I imagine.
I've never tried one,
but,
but I,
you know,
on the conservation side,
you,
you know,
they're competitors for a resource.
So,
you know,
it's a tough one.
Very tough one.
Yeah.
I mean,
I want the for,
you know,
I want to get a fur collar.
It doesn't,
it doesn't,
uh,
frost up,
you know,
that and Wolverine,
don't even over neither.
So would you kill that?
Uh,
yeah,
it's a,
it's a tougher one.
You know,
it's a tough one,
but they're carnivores and you're,
you're,
you know,
as a hunter,
you've got a dot.
An animosity towards him.
But certainly there's a competitive,
uh,
competition between them and us for the same resource.
So there's,
you know,
it's almost like a justification in that way,
but because you can't have them and have wildlife,
you know,
like,
like the unusual,
it's living in the same place.
You just can't have,
you know,
cause walls will kill them all.
They will,
you know,
anyone that says wools only killed the,
the,
the old and the infirm bullcrap that,
you know,
they will kill an entire herd of Caribou if they can't just for fun,
just for fun and eat what they can.
And then on the go,
you know,
the,
wasted meet,
yeah.
Wasted meat and walls will kill them all that,
that they're,
they're killing machines.
So it's uh,
yeah,
it's a,
it's a much tougher on hyenas over and over and Africa.
There they are predators.
They try and paint them as non predators.
You know,
they're,
they're scavengers and take away from the lions,
pull crop,
they're killers.
And then when the wild dogs over there kill,
kill,
kill there,
they're very efficient predators,
you know?
So do you kill that Hyena to save 50,
uh,
you know,
pick a impala,
can you justify that?
If you,
if your job as a conservationist is to increase numbers of ungulates,
but still still maintain a balance on the predators,
you know,
there's the key,
right?
Maintain the balance.
So,
you know,
how do,
how do ya,
how do you justify you kill them.
You don't eat them but,
but you're increasing the numbers of annulets.
You know,
and again,
we're,
we're kind of playing God and some of this stuff
where I was in BC,
there's no bag limit on wolves.
They can shoot as many words as you want.
They were the guys who are there.
The hunting guy that I was with,
um,
big country outfitters and some of the people that I met in the town,
they were describing like the wolf situations out of control.
They have wolves took down a cow.
My uh,
friend's neighbor,
2000 pound cow is just bowls descended upon.
It just started ripping it apart.
They looked out the window,
they heard howling and the craziness and these wolves are ripping apart cow.
Yeah,
there,
there's a lot of walls up there and there and they breed quickly.
You know,
they'll have litter of five,
six babies and they have five or six babies within two years of is,
it's a number that increases very quickly as it were saying in Yellowstone
ballpark.
I ran into a guy at the airport.
Really Interesting Guy Cause uh,
he,
uh,
saw that I was checking in a rifle when I was coming back and he was a hunter
but,
uh,
just very,
very intelligent,
articulate guy.
But he was talking to me about how much he enjoys hunting walls and like that's
a crazy subject to dis trike up at somebody because if you just randomly struck
up,
you know,
he's a moose hunter,
but he enjoys hunting the wolves because they're a huge,
they'd just decimate the them,
the moose populations and decimate the elk and the deer populations.
And he was just talking about how this tract of land,
he owns a large piece of land up there about how he's driven the wolves off of
his land because he's killed so many of them there.
But there's no way you even put a dent in the population.
He's like,
it's a Gel.
Like people,
they have this idea of what it is in the city and what he was telling me about
what the p,
the people that,
uh,
a hunted with were telling me about,
that they had a situation where these wolves,
they were taking the wolves and they would take the Alpha male and they were,
it's spam.
They would a nude room,
take his balls and release him back into the wild.
They thought that was going to control the population.
So then they came back after a couple of years and there was a huge increase in
the amount of wolves because the pack that existed that had this one alpha male
was overrun by another pack that realized that they were weak.
The these other,
there's other wolves came in and go,
look at these motherfuckers.
It's guy doesn't even have any balls,
so they kill him.
They killed him,
probably ate them and then just swarmed.
And there was just a hundred more wolves than there were before.
And they're like,
well,
this is fucking crazy.
It didn't work at all like this.
These the best laid plans of mice and men,
you know,
it just
of getting off to stray.
Yeah,
that's a,
I mean,
you know,
it was good intentions and I mean if you're trying to avoid killing a wolf,
that's one way to do it I guess.
But if you're trying to manage the population of wolves,
this is ludicrous.
So it makes no sense.
Well,
they were describing that the people in Vancouver are,
it's also the same province,
it's the same area.
And the people in Vancouver,
they're all urban,
they're living in cities.
They think wolves are cute and they're voting on how all this goes down.
And then the people who were up there in the Bush,
you know,
they're here in the Howells every now and then like she'll fuck these guys.
Like,
come hang out with me.
Come,
come,
come be up here and come take a look at history.
Come take a look at the fact that wolves killed 40 people in Paris one year in
the 14 hundreds or during World War One when they actually had to call a cease
fire between the Russians and the Germans because they were getting so many of
them were getting killed by wolves.
They said,
listen,
they were in Russia and they go,
look,
just stop killing each other for a little bit.
Fuck these wolves up,
drop the populations down and then go back to business.
Like that's a very rare or a rarely discussed piece of history and actual cease
fire between Russians and Germans just to do
with wolves killing soldiers.
And I've heard of,
I've heard right now they have issues up there again,
they're packs of 60 70 walls running around taking down horses,
taking Oh kill everything.
That's,
I mean,
and to say the wolves won't attack humans.
They said,
they say that that's,
that's absolute bunk.
You know,
in Saskatchewan a couple of years ago a guy was killed,
you know,
the scientists tried to say,
oh,
it's maybe a bare of,
I mean it's a wolf,
it's a wolf.
Kill Them.
There was an attack in British Columbia recently too,
on one of the islands.
Again,
Wolf,
you know,
so they will,
they will attack.
And that the,
the biggest problem is we've made it easy for the wolves to kill animals.
You know,
we build roads.
Soon as you build a road,
whether it's a logging road,
a trail,
Skeeter trail,
doesn't matter.
The rules can run that trail much easier than they can over rough terrain.
So they run that trail until they hit a track of,
uh,
you know,
a Mousse and then they off they go kill the Moose back on the trail,
run it until they hit a track of a deer,
kill it.
You know,
elk kill it.
We've made it too easy for them to survive.
So we've actually,
you know,
people say,
let nature take care of it,
boom and bust.
That's not what's happening.
It's not natural.
We have built roads,
so we've made their advantage to grate over the ungulates Va.
We've added an unnatural element.
Exactly.
So pretty natural because it's humans.
We've done a beaver makes a damn right.
But then it's also natural for us to manage that population of wolves to kill
them.
So back to your question.
Oh,
how do you,
how do you justify it?
Wolf?
I,
you know,
I don't have a problem justifying killing a wolf.
You know,
the Hyena over in Africa,
that money for the trophy fees goes to the village.
So the Hyena died.
But in general it helped a while a population as a whole,
you know,
if you get into the,
the deep philosophical question of it,
biologically,
it makes no difference that that animal got killed.
It was going to die anyway.
You know,
it's,
everybody dies,
everything dies.
And how it dies is irrelevant.
You know,
as long as the population is stable or,
or even growing,
then it doesn't matter why you killed it.
And ultimately as hunters,
you don't really need to justify it to anybody.
Why you hunted?
I hunt because I hunt.
I hunt and killing as part of hunt.
You know,
that's,
it's,
it's what I do.
So,
so I,
you know,
but put to to couch it in terms of a non hunter would understand why you killed
that Hyena.
It was very difficult.
Very,
it's very difficult.
And I,
you know,
since elephants are big one,
that's a,
that's a hot point.
That's the mean.
You said earlier that you've hunted elephants.
We say,
I want to kill an elephant to someone named the almost universal reaction in a
city.
He's like,
you're an asshole.
I want to kill an elephant answer.
You're an asshole to,
you know,
the elephant situation over there is so tragic.
Uh,
I was in cr a couple of years ago and we were between the elephant herd and the
Sudanese rebels.
They were on horseback and chasing after the elephants and popcorn with AK 47
just popped up dup,
dup,
and we were between them.
This,
you know,
they went right by us.
They,
they shoot him,
kill him.
The entire herd babies.
Doesn't matter if it's got a pound of ivory,
it's going to get killed.
Then following them are the,
the pack trains of camels and more donkeys with the people that then butcher up.
The elephants at the horseback,
riders have killed.
They were literally extra painting the elephant from car.
And I,
at this point right now,
I,
I tried to get back into a bang we last year,
but it was,
it was the civil war was going on and I air France wasn't even flying in there.
I just have a feeling that CR elephants are gone.
They're gone.
Um,
we're having the same thing now on camera,
on the northern Savannah regions of Cabernet when they were five years ago,
there's elephants everywhere.
Gone.
I was in Tanzania and the Solu,
the slew is the largest game reserve in the world.
It was,
it was,
uh,
what,
how big is it?
Uh,
uh,
it'll come to me with 6 million acre or something,
something just absolutely enormous.
And when I was there five years ago,
I probably saw,
I dunno,
a thousand elephants,
there were 90,000,
98,000 elephants in the Solu 10 years ago.
Today they feel there may be 8,000 altogether.
And I was just there.
We did an uncharted segments in the aunt on the Solu and on the elephants.
I found skull after skull after skull faces chainsawed off,
uh,
ivory gone.
And these are young elephants,
their young ones,
you know,
they're,
they're actually,
you know,
the shooting,
cause it's easy to carry the ivory.
It's,
they're going to shoot everything and two pounds of ivory,
they're going to kill it.
So it's just the unbelievably difficult circumstances that they find themselves
in as human beings.
Like they're almost forced into this horrible situation because they're
incredibly impoverished and there's nothing else for them there.
There's no other resources.
Is that what the cases
yeah,
there's big money to,
and you know,
not only at their level,
it's big money.
Maybe they get what they're saying.
They get $300 for an elephant,
you know,
just to 10 pounds of ivory.
The money that,
that I read then goes to the middleman who then goes to another middle man who
then another middle man and finally,
you know,
to the big guys and get shipped out.
There's huge money at high levels in those African countries.
Um,
I mean,
I,
I think we'd be surprised at who is behind a lot of the WHO's making money off
the poaching of the ivory.
And the only thing that in the saloon that was stopping the poaching where the
hunters,
the hunters were there,
but it was too little.
It was just not enough.
We needed a,
we needed a a thousand times more hunters in there that we'd had a thousand
times more dollars.
You could have kept the poachers out.
Yeah,
you're losing some of the older bulls,
but they're,
you know,
very carefully controlled,
very carefully harvested out of this herd.
Not when it happens to be poaching it,
everything gets wiped out.
Babies,
mothers doesn't matter.
And I,
you know,
there's a case of where the hunting dollars just weren't enough,
but the hunters were the only ones between the poachers and the elephants and,
and you just can't hold back that tide.
There's too many poachers,
too much demand from Asia,
and not enough money on the hunting side to,
to finance the anti poaching patrols that you need it,
you know,
and,
and you know,
now,
after the,
they're pretty well decimated,
the government's come back in and they're starting to impose heavy fines for
poaching now in Tanzania,
you know,
20 years if you're caught with,
with poached meat.
And if you're an elephant,
you're,
you know,
you're going to jail for life if you don't get shot,
on the way to jail.
There are serious about it now.
But,
but it begs a question,
why did they wait until now?
Why did they wait til 90,000 elephants were killed in the last 10 years in one
area,
one easily to protect area with,
you know,
it takes money,
but why were they killed?
Who was making the money?
Follow the money.
And that's when you'll find out the reason why the that happened.
You know?
And I think we'd be surprised.
Like I say,
who's behind it when they stop hunting?
You open the doors for the poachers and uh,
it's,
it's a tough one.
I mean,
it's really,
really sad.
Then Botswana shuts down hunting altogether.
You know,
very wealthy country,
lots of tourism and too many elephants.
The elephants are actually ruining the ecosystems near the river Rhine Habitat.
You're going to walk 10 miles to find a tree that's not been torn down in some
places.
You know,
everything that relied on those trees,
that ecosystem is dead and gone.
All the antelope that required the trees and there's too many elephants for the
habitat now in South Africa,
they used to go in and rent up until I'd say the 70s they were,
they were calling them,
they would walk in and kill the entire herd off.
You know,
cause they knew there's too many elephants.
They actually reproduced too quickly when they're protected.
So you end up with this,
this two sided problem.
Too many elephants in Botswana,
elephants being wiped out by Sudanese poachers and places like cr,
Cameroon,
even Congo there,
they're everywhere now.
Tanzania,
a Somali poachers are coming down into Tanzania.
It's a,
it's a really,
really sad thing.
And that,
that,
that's,
that's one where I don't see the,
uh,
I,
I don't see a solution for it.
I honestly don't.
I don't,
I just think that the world,
it's,
it's like Lord of the rings where the Elvis realized this world isn't for us
anymore.
And the elephants,
I'm a,
I'm really,
really,
really afraid that they're just no hope for them in spite of the dollars that
hunters put in to these areas to stop poaching.
I,
it's a,
it's a real sad one for me.
Have you ever seen,
do you know who Louis Theroux is thorough,
thorough,
and he said,
well,
I said,
I,
you it,
I'm probably said it wrong.
I think,
I think he said that through,
right.
Anyway,
um,
he's a documentary guy from England.
Great Guy,
had him on the podcast for a very,
very interesting guy.
And he had a great piece about Africa and about the hunting camps in Africa.
And,
uh,
one of the most profound moments in it was when he's kind of talking to this guy
who runs this wild game farm and he's annoying the guy and you know,
the guy,
he's been there for like three weeks talking to them and videotaping him.
The guy shows him all the lions that they,
they're feeding lines or throwing a calf over the like,
it's just like Jurassic Park.
They throw this calf over the fence of lions,
tear it apart in front of them.
It's like wild shit.
Um,
but he's talking to this guy and finally the guide just sort of breaks down and
he's like,
you don't get it.
Like Africa is fucked.
Like this is the only thing that keeps these animals alive is the fact there
were something like this is,
this is what keeps him alive.
If it wasn't for that,
they'd be nothing.
They would just destroy everything.
No,
the Africa is in dire straits and as I say,
Africa is being colonized right now.
You know,
to me,
you can call a nice two different ways militarily or economically in Africa is
being colonized economically.
And if you look at the track record of WHO's colonizing Africa,
you know,
the wildlife track record.
And I,
you know,
and again this,
you're talking,
this is big world politics that who am I?
I'm a little guy that sits on a mountain and just looks at stuff and sees it
hopefully objectively.
And if this Africa,
20 years from now,
you know,
they're the only place you're going to probably find wildlife is going to be on
the parks.
Wow.
And that's,
you know,
hunting is,
is helping,
you know,
the parks will be bigger because of hunting.
We can hold them back on the,
on the boundaries of the park of buffer zone,
but,
but it's,
uh,
it's actually really,
it's really sad that we set up a feet on the ground thing,
as you said,
like you've,
unless you're there,
you don't truly understand the situation.
Yeah.
I mean,
we,
we get,
we get fed,
you know,
the propaganda from our press,
right.
Uh,
and,
and a lot of it's sensationalism.
What sells the,
the go talk to somebody in Africa that,
that's living the life there and see what they say about Ivan Carter.
Pull that back down.
Jamie.
Don't scroll it.
It Chinese Africans knew.
Colonial overlord says fame,
primate research.
Jane Goodall.
You know what else Jane Goodall's house.
Big Foot's real.
So yeah.
So take it with a grain of salt.
Yeah,
I've,
I've actually heard,
I know quite a few people that know her and they say she's,
she's a you,
she'll drink beer and she'll slice to party you.
Yeah.
Oh,
she'll,
she's not afraid of cuss words and she'll huh?
Yeah,
that's what I've heard.
And I don't know Jane,
I'm sorry for this thing with,
she's probably a huge fan of yours and she's listening right now over and,
oh,
I have no idea.
I should probably thinks I'm an idiot.
More likely.
But she does believe in big foot.
Is that right?
Is She's just a,
there's a,
um,
well,
I have to play the clip.
We played it,
played it before,
but she is convinced that there's some unknown primate.
I think there's someone owned primary,
I don't think there's a question about that,
but there'll will be in the Democratic Republic of Congo somewhere it was
[inaudible] was or whatever they call it.
Yeah.
Well do you know about that?
Uh,
the Billy ape or the,
the uh,
uh,
this,
this giant a chimpanzee that they've found in the Congo,
uh,
may have heard about it.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
there's this version of a chimpanzee that they found in the Congo that's much
larger.
It's about six feet tall.
Sometimes there's one of them.
They,
uh,
they can get up to like 400 pounds and enormous chimpanzee.
Is that the ones that are,
they're quite friendly or they don't fight or something or they know that's it.
But no bows because those are smaller.
Actually.
Those are,
uh,
those are like the least violent.
Um,
these ones,
the locals call them lion killers.
What was the other term?
Form the,
but no,
not,
it's not the Bondo.
The bondo,
the Bondo.
Ayp.
And they,
they thought it was a myth until like 19,
the 1990s.
Carl Amon is a Swiss wildlife photographer,
became infatuated with them and started using camera traps and got a photo of
one walking upright.
It's very strange when you see this thing that's very odd.
Chimpanzee the six foot Tall Chimpanzee walking upright say yeah,
they nest on the ground like gorillas.
Yup.
Cause they really don't give a shit who's looking at anything.
Toughest guys.
They're just,
they're,
you know,
when a chimpanzee walks up to your wild one there,
there are frightening animal.
Oh yeah.
Scary looking,
scary acting.
Have you seen him in the wild?
Oh yeah.
A lot.
Yeah.
Grillers as well.
And the chimps would come up to you in the wild,
like what is that experience like?
Well they're there.
Normally if they come up to us it's because we're calling for Dikers,
a little
forest antelope,
you know,
there's all,
there's 20 or 30 different species that live in the jungles very far to very
difficult to hunt.
And so what we do is we sneak around and then set up,
sit down,
call [inaudible] trying for whatever reason,
the Dikers come to this distress call and they'll come running in.
But they're not the only things that come into the distress calls.
They,
the chimpanzees are carnivorous.
They'll come in absolutely 100% to come and kill whatever is making that noise
and eat it.
So when they come in there,
they're nasty,
nasty,
and big.
They're big.
You know,
you see the muscles,
how they're ripped.
It's a,
it's a frightening thing.
Grill is not,
you know,
grill,
grill is,
are big as well and,
and surely vegetarian.
Yeah,
they don't,
they,
it was scary.
Like they,
they will turn you inside out when one comes out of the Bush at you just
shaking all the trees right in front of you.
And then they're gone.
They got killed by the pygmies.
They get eaten their food source.
So they're,
they hate people.
Hate people.
Isn't that crazy?
They're,
they'll eat gorillas.
Those,
yeah,
they're,
they're an amazing animal.
I last year I spent,
uh,
I was in a Mishawn,
again on the border with,
with the Congo and had a troop of will a nine or 11,
uh,
gorilla's come in with one big silver back and they for 40 minutes in front of
us,
like 20 hours.
No idea.
We were there.
It was fantastic.
And these aren't,
these aren't the habituated once from Rwanda.
You know that everybody goes and pays their $20 and sits there and don't look in
their eyes.
These are the ones will kill you if there,
if you look,
look in your eyes not looking your eyes.
If they see you,
their kill you.
Wow.
Yeah.
Scary animals.
And they had no idea where their video on the whole time.
It was fantastic.
Wow,
that's amazing.
Now do you have a rifle ready to go if they make a run for you?
Yeah.
Which you would never kill.
What?
I mean you'd,
you'd scare them.
I don't,
you know,
there's a body language.
I think they would,
they would bluff charge every time I've ever seen him.
It's always been a bluff charge.
I've never seen one press a charge right to the very end,
but I wouldn't see it if I did.
I would be here.
I saw bluff charge online ones.
Oh,
this guy standing there in this silver back comes charging out of the woods,
right up to the guy and then just turns away.
But the guy just stands there and stands his ground.
But this enormous beast,
I mean I don't know how many hundred of pounds he weighed probably five,
600 pounds,
just running full charge,
just full of sin,
you and giant fangs and you're like,
Oh God,
how do you stand still
monsters and the,
and they also roar like a visceral,
scary feeling inside anybody that's got ears,
you can,
it just
turned you in a jelly.
It's they're scary.
Or they'll charge your truck.
I've had them on those little overgrown logging roads come out just right in
front of why runs down there and then into the bushes and shake the bushes.
Scares the heck out of here.
That's,
it's a,
it's a neat thing.
And you know,
they're not habituated animals.
These are,
these are animals that live wild and free hate humans you for a good reason.
They get hunted down.
Is there anything that you haven't hunted that you want to hunt that like is on
your list of things to go after that you have had difficulty finding maybe?
Yeah,
I've been out.
I'd love to go into Baluchistan on the border with,
uh,
I didn't even know that was a real place.
John Belushi came from,
now it's a province in Pakistan.
Danger.
Got to go back to Pakistan.
While I might not be able to after what I've said here today,
but please just answer.
It's a fascinating place.
And then it seems like there's an animal called a Sulaiman mark whore,
which it'll Jason and the fleece.
That was probably what he was after was a Sulivan mark.
Jason in the fleece.
It's a Greek tale or I assume it as Jason is Jason and the argonauts.
No,
the golden fleece.
Who was,
it wasn't adjacent.
I don't know.
Was talking to this.
Maybe I got my,
uh,
my mythical heroes.
It was probably after this animal,
what's it called again?
The Sulaiman mark whore.
Suliman mark.
He got straight horns with,
with kind of a corkscrew on them.
And the only place you can hunt them is there.
And it's kind of a,
a real if place right now,
but they,
they have allowed I think five to 10 of these to be hunted a year.
It's all controlled by the warlords over there,
but sites,
they've got scientists in there and they're these,
these warlords or are educated in the states or England that they're,
you know,
they're not dumb guys.
They speak English very well and they understand conservation there.
You know,
they just pick one side this week and one side that week,
you know,
depends on what's going on.
But,
but they are for conservation of these animals and they get a lot of money for
them.
They're extremely expensive.
What do they call themselves?
We call them war lords.
That's a,
seems that it's a strange,
almost archaic designation.
Is this the animal?
Uh,
that's actually a cashmere more core.
it also could be a look at the horns on that thing.
Yeah.
There,
there's about three or four different species.
There's a,
what's the other one?
The uh,
oh,
I was just there.
There's that.
There's a silicon mark or in the middle.
Middle.
Top.
Wow.
Look at that thing.
Yeah,
it's,
wow.
That's,
that's like a drill.
Like an oil drill growing out of its head.
Yeah.
Like two opposing oil drills.
Wow.
What a strange looking out and that's when obviously that's somebody hunted.
Yeah,
it's dead and there the Sula and mark or I'd love to go.
You could also hunt the Afghan urial there and I've not heard that either.
So those two animals,
I'd love to get into that problem.
Sure.
So bizarre.
I mean,
even an elk or a moose,
this idea,
they grow these antlers on their head.
He's enormous racks of login trees grown out of their heads every year.
That's the hard thing to believe.
They drop them every spring and then grow.
What?
50 pounds of Horn?
Like a,
an antler on a,
on a moose.
That's African euro.
They keep it rams.
Keep it all their lives.
Yeah.
That's horn.
The only one that drops its horns or is the antelope,
the pronghorn antelope will the sheath,
the outside will drop off every year.
Otherwise,
otherwise,
horn animals grow every year.
Antler an animals drop theirs and regrown memory or a passage going born in the
world.
Antlered animals that drop him.
Like how long do they have no antlers.
Like an elk,
like saying when the elk sheds a lot depends on the season.
Uh,
what the year's going to be like.
If it's a rough winter coming up.
Seems to be they dropped earlier.
They don't want to carry those,
you know,
soon as the ruts over,
off they go,
and then they're,
you know,
not caring it.
There was all there basically testosterone,
I guess.
So that's what causes them to drop.
And the only animal that's a female that carries them as Caribou.
Right.
And does that to defend against wolves and bears.
And who knows what the reason they're on their head,
but they,
you know,
they're,
they're so tiny.
I would,
would never protect them from a wolf.
Oh,
they really small compared to the males.
Males are huge,
you know,
largest antlered animal compared to body size.
Largest antlers compared to body size of any,
any animal.
Yeah.
They don't even look real like you.
If you care about the shovels and all the crazy stuff,
they get grown off their head like that's,
that's like a Whoville thing.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Something from doctor said.
Exactly.
No,
it's fascinating.
They're there.
Caribou or an underrated big game animal love hunting and Mountain Caribou
particularly.
That's,
that's of all the Caribou species.
That's my favorite to hunt.
And do you prefer like when you,
you're going into these,
these places,
do you prefer to do it with a camera crew or do you get a chance to hunt where
you just hunt sometimes?
No.
Well
I don't,
I would have difficulty hunting without a camera crew.
And the reason is because it's become part of the challenge.
It's,
it's far more difficult to hunt when you've got to drag along,
at least one guy sometimes too.
And you can only,
you can't shoot into the sun.
You can't.
If there's a flakes on the lands,
we've got to call it off.
If they can't get an in focus,
if I could shoot where they can't see it,
if it's too dark for them to see,
but it's legal light and I can see it.
I can't shoot and has to be broad side head up.
You know,
you start throwing in all of these extra degrees of difficulty.
It to me,
it's become part of the challenge of the hunt nowadays.
And I want to share it with everybody.
I mean,
I'm in a,
I'm in a position in my life and in my career where I can,
you know,
I'm able to,
so why wouldn't I share it with the guys that can't go along.
There are hunters that maybe,
you know,
they would love to,
maybe they don't have the money,
maybe they don't have the time.
Maybe they,
you know,
for whatever reason can't do it.
My goal when I started doing the television hunting television was to bring all
of these fellow hunters with me.
You know,
they're there with me as much as they can be.
They're not pulling the trigger,
but their experience and exactly what I'm experiencing.
So to me,
to,
it's a responsibility now and,
and it's also a challenge and I love it.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I wanna I want,
I'm proud of being a hunter and I want to share it with,
with other hunters that want to watch or with people that want to learn about
conservation and why hunting is good.
So,
so to me to not hunt with a camera would be,
why would I kill then?
It's other than to eat it,
you know,
so it's,
uh,
I don't know,
maybe as part of the reason I,
you know,
justification for hunting.
Do you eat any store bought meat?
Well,
you know,
if,
if I'm at our convention season's coming up,
so there'll be,
I'll be wine and dine and taken to the fanciest steakhouses around and that's in
Vegas at the shot show shot show.
Yeah,
that'll be,
that'll be one of the shows with sci.
And we've got Ata,
the archery trade show,
um,
the Dallas Safari Club,
you know,
so,
so yeah,
I will eat,
store bought meat,
but it's always in those kinds of situations.
I can't,
I can't recall last time Louisie or you know,
brought store,
bought meat into our house.
I mean it's just not,
I mean we live on Moose and Caribou and deer,
you know,
bear,
if we have it,
if it sits,
it's what we eat now.
Bear not so much.
I've,
I've eaten lots of bears in my life so I prefer to share the bears with southern
people.
It's not my favorite is still good,
but it's not my favorite.
But uh,
to buy me to it makes no sense.
Why would we do eat grizzly?
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
What does that like?
I've heard it's disgusting.
No,
now that,
that's,
that's such bonk on the,
the,
the people that say that while game is Gamey,
it's all in the preparation.
So if you're,
if if it goes,
he's been eating salmon for instance,
and,
and you cut a big chunk of steak off and a big swath of fat on it and you know,
fry it up.
Well guess what?
It smells like.
Smells like rotten fish.
Cause guess that's what he's been eating,
right?
We get rid of the fat and just take off the mile and cheating and just have the
meat.
It's excellent.
Same as polar bear.
It's,
it's good.
You know,
black bears are excellent.
I mean,
most of the time they just eat,
uh,
eat berries and grass,
clover,
whatever.
I was amazed at how good blackberry tastes.
No,
it's really good.
That's really good.
As one of the things that I,
that I got criticized for,
people were telling me that back black bears tasted terrible.
Like,
why do you want to shoot something that you're not going to eat?
And I was really concerned.
I was like,
man,
who's telling the truth here?
Until I actually tried it,
I tried it before actually shot one and I was like,
oh,
they're just lying.
Or they don't know or can't I define anybody to tell that they're reading a
black bear as opposed to,
I mean,
I honestly,
I suspect I could,
you know,
sausage for sure.
No one's ever gonna know.
Uh,
you'd never tell.
And even from other wild game.
I don't think you could tell,
but I suspect you wouldn't build a tell it from a even beef,
a few of us prepared properly.
If it's in a stew,
there's no way it's,
it's,
it's good.
It's good.
It's not my favorite.
I have to know that I'm allowed to have favorites.
I like Moose.
That's,
if I'm going to live on something for the winter.
It's Moose.
Moose is amazing.
Yeah.
Ribs move through.
The best of the best for about game animals like Moose or elk or venison is that
you can eat it rare.
He didn't like medium rare.
That's the only way to eat it.
You don't want to overcook it and you have to sear the outside seal in the
juices so it looks,
when you cut it,
you swear,
oh,
that's way too rare.
But you let that sit there for another half an hour off the heat and it'll go
all,
you know,
Brown like it's,
it's cooked.
You just,
it's just,
they're so juicy and so,
I mean,
flavor folder there.
You got eat him like that.
You have to be careful of overcooking that kind of games,
especially on who's right.
Yeah.
Sear,
sear the outside.
Don't,
don't overcook the inside.
You can't.
You have to leave a juicy because there's no fat.
These animals have very little fat on them,
and if it is on a deer,
it's tally.
It's not,
not the same kind of fad is on a,
on a cow,
so you're normally,
you trim the fat off on any wild game if it,
if they have any,
but the,
in the actual muscles themselves,
there's no fat.
It's,
it's a,
it's a fairly dry meat,
so you have to,
you have to prepare it properly.
We're now recently got a trick analysis from that.
You know what?
I heard your podcast with him talking about the chicken houses.
I was kind of giggling about that.
What's Hilarious,
because he was always talking about chicken gnosis the dangers of tricking us
and the,
if you watch his show,
he was with this guy,
a Rourke Denver,
who's a navy seal,
took him out for his first haunt ever.
They shot a bear and you're watching them cook the bear and you're like,
that is not cooked.
Do you really gonna to eat that?
It's his red.
And he wound up getting tricky noses from it.
Yeah,
I mean that's,
uh,
I heard the podcast,
I was kind of giggling.
I'm,
I was,
while I was in Africa,
I mean,
there,
I'm worrying about three foot long Guinea worms and microfilaria and Belle has
the,
I mean,
real serious stuff.
Chicken Osis says,
you know,
I mean,
that's,
I'm sure a lot of us are carrying that around.
We just don't know it.
Really.
You think you have it?
I don't think I do.
Of course.
But
I know one thing when I come back from these trips,
my wife will occasionally say,
Oh,
I've made a doctor's appointment for you.
And so I'm fine,
I'm healthy,
I'm good.
And she says,
you're going into the doctor and you're getting dewormed.
Right.
So she,
she doesn't,
I know I don't have chicken houses or any of these crazy parasites,
but,
uh,
you know,
just for insurance,
my wife does send me to the doctor to take a course of whatever,
horse pills,
whatever.
There's some weird stuff out there in Africa especially,
I'm sure that's as about as wild as it gets for now.
For now.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
you know,
in actual people places the,
the Yukon is,
is more remote than anywhere in Africa,
anywhere in Asia.
That's Russia.
There's some pretty remote places,
but they're usually,
there's people there somewhere,
but,
uh,
you know,
Yukon North America,
we still have some of the most remote lands left in this planet.
We're very fortunate.
Jim Shockey,
you're an awesome dude.
This is really,
really enjoyable podcast.
I was looking forward to it for a long time and,
uh,
I've,
I really appreciate you taking your time to come down here and I really want
people to watch your television program.
Uncharted is an amazing program.
Whether you like hunting or not,
it's more of a,
a documentary on the culture than it is just a hunting show.
It's,
it really does transcend the genre and a real honor and a pleasure having you on
here.
Thank you very much,
my honor.
You're doing great work and I'll support that any day.
All right,
fine.
Jim On Facebook.
Uh,
what is your Facebook page?
Jim Shockey and Twitter.
Same thing.
Jim Shockey and then underscore after Shockey.
Right.
Thank you very much,
sir.
Really appreciate it.
Tell you betcha you,
Joe,
thanks for having us do this again some time.
Anytime you want me to hunting.
I do that too.
That would be really fun.
Come on.
Let's do it.
I'll do it for your show.
Coming to my house next time.
I would love it.
Let's do it.
You,
here we go.
All right.
Thanks everybody.
We'll see you soon.
Bye.
Hmm.